e
good morning
everyone um pledge allegiance
us thank
you so before we jump into all of the
fun stuff that I want to remind
everybody of or introduce them too um I
am your chairman uh representative Greg
Hill been here since 2010 uh been
chairing this
committee I think this is the third
yeah good segue this is our vice
chairman uh or co-chairman as I
sometimes say um Vanessa Sheen uh this
is her second term as Vice chair she
previously sat as clerk in this
committee um so we've the advantage is
for everyone is we've seen a lot of
these bills before um and we kind of
know what's coming so uh that's a good
thing I think um in addition to
legislative Administration I've also
served on education labor with
representative turot um election law
transportation
and this so um I've got kind of a
working knowledge of wherever you want
to go I don't think anybody else is in
second committees right you only have
one committee yeah so that um we both
are in second committees so you'll find
for us sometimes there's overlap and we
have information from what went on in a
different committee um and that that too
is
helpful um we also have a new clerk who
is an experienced clerk you came from
Edna Edna last year which is Vanessa's
second committee so uh it's kind of
every Small World stuff um do you want
to tell us a little bit about
yourself um well is my second term I've
enjoyed it um Edna was very busy
committee and um too busy for me so I'd
asked to uh to be on a less busy one so
here I am more important but less busy
yeah yeah
so but yeah it's got a lot of good
people here so I look forward to it
working with with with you all so we're
probably going to need a
pronunciation okay we were just talking
about that oh um my family pronounced it
sway sway sir sway it's sway yeah the
original pronunciation would be sir but
my family says sway okay like I
explained to them it breaks the
association with the French King which
is what the is so it's not a it it is it
from um are you French Canadian so my
family settled into northern Maine but
they were sent here from the French can
to populate that's what the S with Sir W
means is gentleman of the
C
okay
um never mind um so why don't we um at
least uh run around quickly around the
friendly committee um it's generally not
an a partisan committee uh it
is we all seem to be working the the the
way things used to work here um we we
tend to look at bills on their merits
and uh regardless of who Prime sponsors
are or other sponsors we look at uh
whether it's a good piece of legislation
and whether it will
help State of New Hampshire and
primarily the legislature operate um so
uh those that have been in this before I
think will testify that it is um it is
a
um easy committee to work with um we
tend
to she's locked down Karen um we tend to
have a
uh um quite a few bills that even even
though we have a very small number we
tend to have a very large number great
um of bills that end up on the consent
calendar um so uh which speaks a little
bit to um to how we do our work and that
we talk things out before we uh finally
vote in exec
session um yeah maybe that's
best
um this is interesting
okay um so what we have uh this is while
while I have the opportunity um this is
our uh very fine committee assistant uh
that's here to make us look good um and
our
okay uh 12 of them right okay and
there's still possibility of additional
okay um so would you like to tell us a
little bit about what you do for us or
do you want
okay go
sure Davis my colleague
jie last year everything I know I learn
from J I know I pict
F I am the uh person that and setting up
and then I also take all the and all the
bills and I create the files and track
everything session and then files done
andiz
to what other committees are you
handling I'm the assistant for all the
Committees on this side
so that's education policy education
funding education policy Transportation
transportation
services
and oh nothing no big deal no big deal
um can you also talk to us a little bit
about um committee reports and your
involvement with
auth on theft
to so in the past we've had people with
very poor
penmanship um so we have uh talked about
um whether it would be better and it's
kind of up to all of us to decide
whether would be better to submit
um to submit in uh electronically if you
prefer that I think it probably helps
you so that you can cut and paste and
put things in um but we still are able
to you're
not no you can you're you're perfectly
welcome all right that's great yeah you
keep an eye on Paul um
you can be our security officer for the
day you can be our security officer for
the day
yeah yeah all right um I don't know if
everybody knows but this is uh the
ranking member uh Janet wall um who has
served on this committee
for more than I have um but um and also
been chair of Judiciary and a number of
other things um if if she doesn't know
it the answer to your question that it
doesn't it hasn't come up before um so
as far as the committee um reports if
there was a way of making
sure um they're legible and uh once once
you complete them I have to sign off on
them so um that'll be the first catch if
I can't read it um I'll probably coming
back and saying how do we do this
Jamie's laughing already because she uh
saw me do that several times um but uh
it would be great if we can get those in
as quickly as we can so that we can get
them into the calendar and into um um
the house as quickly as possible and as
cleanly as possible and as U written as
well as possible
um
right um anything we need from Karen now
yep yeah that would be great I when we
get the notice about the bills can they
attach this to the email with all the
details because I like to print them out
ahead of time I don't know what you're
saying do you know when you send the
when she sends out the email that says
we're having a hearing or this or that
that attach sometimes it was just I
think one of the emails was just like
the schedule but didn't attach the
actual email the actual bill PDF of the
bill stuff yeah well you should have all
of the bills now she's passing oh she's
passing them okay great so when you get
that note you you can combine them okay
you yep yep so you should be set um I
tend to keep all of mine in a three-
ring binder um just because I can but um
you do what you do you um one thing that
is going to be different that I'm going
to try and I'm going to ask you if you
can if I can
um if you can volunteer for this so um
you'll notice when I schedule those and
this is what triggered it when you
mentioned the scheduling p P um you'll
notice that I schedule things usually 15
20 minutes apart and and the reason for
that is it irritates me it's very hard
to schedule or know how long um a
hearing is going to go so
um you can either guess and and
invariably I add too much time to it or
I did in the past and that meant we were
sitting around for 15 minutes or 20
minutes before we can start the next
hearing don't like wasting anybody's
time so instead what I do is schedule
them usually shorter than I think that
they're going to go and then um I just
uh keep running right through all of
them we don't have any breaks for the
committee the downside to that is people
may show up um expecting a bill to be
heard at 9 30 and we've started one at
9:15 and it may go to 9:30 um that's the
tradeoff but what I want to do is is
have and I've I think um Vanessa talked
to you yesterday having a h piece of
paper with a large font to say what the
bill number is and have it sit on the
witness table so that that camera when
it's pointing at the witness table will
indicate which Bill we're working on um
and then at least people will see that
are watching on on YouTube um see what
Bill we're we're playing with and they
and know this doesn't sound like what I
wanted to hear at 9:30 um but we're
going to it's going to be important that
we we keep up with that um that we we
have the right Bill shown um so is that
something that I can ask you to do
representative Boy Thanks um I'm going
to kind of skip out of order for some of
this so that we can get people back to
where they want to be um you'll these
are The Usual Suspects that we have in
our in our committee um we don't
generally have large
audiences um for whatever reason we
generally don't have lobbyists um in
this committee who we have are uh are
are three um and first I'm going to ask
um our extraordinary researcher we're
very blessed that we have the top
researcher in the in the country I think
um but uh but Jennifer is here to make
us look good and does um you'll already
seen a piece of her work I had asked J
to put together uh the files for bills
that we've heard previously so that you
have some knowledge about what's coming
and and what we did about it and what we
said about it so that was all uh the
kind of work that that Jen does
everything that she does comes through
me or Vanessa um so we would appreciate
knowing what what's going on um and nine
times out of 10 we'll say that's fine
you know uh
we'll we'll talk to Jen or or you can
talk to Jen um do you want to introduce
yourself and say a few enlightening
things
nice
okay in Prior years we had Jen on the
fourth floor we had a committee room on
the third floor our our committee
assistant was on the second floor and um
and legislative Administration has an
office on the first floor so uh you'll
get your steps in somewhere along the
line here um now we're a little bit
better we're at least two things on the
on the third floor um you're you're good
I I think yeah I don't think we need any
as long as we can get that uh for this
afternoon we can we can get that new
placard that would be great for the
hearings this afternoon
perfect thank
you
um so that uh pretty much covers Jen
unless anyone has any questions how
things will go there no um next we have
uh our very fine house counsel um Mr Cy
or attorney Cy um do you want to tell us
a little bit about uh how you will help
sometimes it's on interesting things
like the Karen Reed case in uh in
Massachusetts but that's a whole another
story um
next we uh we come to uh our very fine
clerk uh house clerk um who which I'm
sure he will explain what his favorite
committee
is good morning everyone sorry I'll use
the mic my uh little little horse today
um Paul Smith Clerk of the house honored
to be with my favorite Committee of the
house and um the reason it is my
favorite Committee of the house is
because this was my committee when I was
in the house 20 plus years ago uh I
actually U was fortunate enough to be
the clerk of this committee uh when I
was a member um and that really being on
this committee um really sort of helped
Foster my love for the institution and
the process and uh so I am grateful uh
for that um couple of things just to as
as Jim mentioned um of course I am a
nonpartisan officer of the house and I
do appear frequent in in this committee
uh to testify and it is always to give
informational purpose uh for
informational purposes um you will see
me uh this afternoon uh there will be a
piece of legislation um that that I will
be testifying on uh and that is because
uh uh it amends the law that I was a
sponsor of uh 22 years ago um and I was
going I'm going to give sort of a
historical uh reference to why that was
enacted uh at that time um and again
that that is part of what I do hear uh
uh Jen mentioned uh you know
corresponding with other uh you know
ncsl and that sort of thing I also have
um uh a former president of the American
Society of legislative clerks and
secretaries and we have um we
communicate a lot uh about various
issues affecting all of our legislator
um uh there will you'll have a bill on
pslf uh for legislators coming up um and
I've been asked to give testimony on
that again um and uh I have information
from other states where clerks are uh
part of that process so um those are the
kind of things that you'll you'll see me
here for um you'll also see me just kind
of um Jim and I just kind of sitting in
the back um uh not always testifying
just just here to keep an eye as he said
a watchful eye over the the stored
institution um but again if you have
questions um about anything particularly
um you know regarding uh our our
practices our customs our preceden Etc
uh I'm always available uh to answer
those uh for you um you know this this
committee is special because it is about
our internal processes um and not just
our internal processes in the house but
really the whole legislature um and and
you know so so sometimes uh as Jim
mentioned you you might hear us talking
about our our current practices and some
of our current practices are because
they are our practices and so the
question is should we let the other body
in the executive branch weigh in on our
practices uh when when bills come before
you so those are those are some things
to think about uh while while you all uh
deliberate on them do we need the Senate
to weigh in on how the house runs Etc so
U those are those are some of the
questions that you'll you'll think about
when you're deliberating um again uh it
is it is a a pleasure to be here um I'm
always happy to uh be available and
answer questions or uh chitchat about uh
rules I I'm real big fan of rules uh our
house rules and and and our
parliamentary procedure so um always
happy to talk to you about that um and
including Nuance stuff um you know we'll
we'll have a continuing education uh
session um probably next month um in the
chamber where we're going to really deep
dive into parliamentary procedure uh so
you'll you'll see me really geek out
that day
um but you know anytime you have
questions about the the why as well as
the how um I'm always happy to talk
about that stuff so thank you very much
and I look forward to working with you
this term thank you very much any
questions for the Clark no we're good um
couple of things uh and and in fact uh
one that you saw earlier conversation
that I was having um because I had
submitted
a possible schedule for the rest of our
bills and uh and it appears that um I've
screwed up for the first time here um
because I've put us on uh the day that
the governor is going to be introducing
uh her budget so um you'll see I don't
think it'll show up in the calendar but
you would have seen our remaining eight
bills um after we have the four this
afternoon the remaining eight bills I
had scheduled for the 20th uh no 13th of
um of February um that's going to be the
day when the governor submits her budget
so we need to decide amongst ourselves
whether we push that for another week um
to the 20th or um would it suit everyone
here uh we're only missing one person I
think uh no two um um whether it would
be better to do it on say the 12th um a
Wednesday um we we are sharing this room
with Transportation they typically have
Tuesday so um it's really up to us to
decide what other day we want to do this
so while I've just already given you
some information
um my information is only as good as as
right after I tell you it and then it
seems like uh it's it's gone so um I
don't know what everyone uh what
everyone um prefers um is there a
preference yep Mr chairman hi everyone
I'm Beth Richards and I represent
conquer and this is I think my third I
think third um yeah and and then prior
to this I was two uh terms in
environment and agriculture so another
committee that was represented um and it
is really helpful um for you to let us
know well in advance and I really
appreciate that when you do that I would
also love to try to lock in on a typical
day um because I run an establishment
that's open seven days a week um so that
is really helpful um so if you're taking
you know favorite days I would love
Thursday the
20th um
here's here we have somewhat of an
advantage because these are going to be
hearings that that we're having those
remaining eight bills on the 13th
schedule now um so because all of them
are recorded um you would have the
ability to to hear them at your leisure
they're not going to be although um it
is in the calendar that um it would be
exec itive sessions are possible in that
time um and again this gets back to the
idea of not wasting anybody's time if we
ran into something where all of a sudden
we had a big block of time that was
available um under rules this year we
are able to exec um a bill um as we have
time so yeah follow up that sure you
mentioned exact would you be expecting
that the bills that we're hearing this
afternoon that you would look to exact
those on the same day and uh on the 20th
that that was seem to be often a
practice that we would hear the bills
and then the next time we meet we would
exact with the possibility but that a
Contin those are those would be the The
Logical ones that I would uh I always
hesitate I think as most chairs do um to
exec a bill the day that we're hearing
it um I just don't I think it's good
idea for people to mull over what
they've heard um but um but so those
four that we hear today would be the
logical ones that we would fill in if
there is time um on
the whatever day we pick I I recall that
you would often indicate that on the
public statements as well so that's um
helpful the public yeah so I in the
schedule that I had sent in and for the
13th I had that line that um
executive um executing bills would be
possible I guess to my point is that I
recalled you indicated the exact bills
from that previous week in that manner
in addition to the catchall line yeah
well we didn't have the catchall line
last term so so we had remembering okay
so we had to do that but um and I still
intend to do that when I know
you know the remaining eight that we're
doing my intention is to just schedule
one day of executing all of those eight
um and and theoretically that would
cover us for this whole half the session
so y sure and and another bill related
thank you for the followup uh is that um
at the time of exec um how would you
like to handle sign
or making comments of what has been
received and comment about the bill that
came from the public um so in my
recollection over the years we would
hear you know there
were uh you know
27 uh submittal and now I'm forgetting
where we are at in our blue cards and
our pink cards but making a statement of
what that was as
we began our discussion so that we're
all informed with the same information
um is that something quite frankly quite
frankly I don't I I I'm not very good at
that um and I
don't um it is up to us to I feel
um to review whatever online testimony
that comes in or not I will occasionally
if there is something that I see that is
particularly on point or um or helpful I
may ask Jen to provide that to all of us
um and and I don't know that maybe
happened twice last year I don't yeah um
but um but
generally uh the idea of
announcing um who or how many votes came
in on on either the signin um sheets the
the blue sheet sheets or
online um because there's 24 hours
after um our hearing to do that I've
never really thought that there's much
use to it um perhaps on on exec session
day um someone is perfectly well welcome
to offer that information but um you
know that's nothing that that uh either
Vanessa or I are are in on our list of
things to do
yep
representating thank you getting back to
the uh schedule um if you push it to the
20th are we sure there's no house
session scheduled that day as of the
moment uh we looked at the magic uh list
that uh the house clerk has and and it's
not there but again that's possible um
anything is possible um
so it would be
safer um if we went off of that Thursday
um
idea um but it would be
um it's completely up to us whatever we
want to do for the record I'm I'm okay
with either either way you you
mentioned um I don't
know maybe uh the vice chair can remind
me was there any was there any dates or
times that
um people could not meet they there were
one um one of the members that's not
here as I recall couldn't make hearings
or exec sessions on the last week of
every
month is that right um but that wouldn't
affect this so um that's the only one I
know so I believe I may have indicated
on a Tuesday it's very difficult
Tuesdays are difficult yeah well we
won't be doing Tuesday is because that
is uh transportation in this room so
that's out um yep are we vot or giving a
preference right now if you have one
mine would be the 20th yeah thank you
you'd push it the week for
further um anybody else preference no
so that could be done too the 12th
about
okay um representative wall you
have ah see that's the ideal answer
right
um well um we'll have to uh maybe we'll
send off an email to the others um that
are coming in
or um more mundane things we also have
to uh start picking up and I have a list
of those um let's let's put that off for
well maybe we need to do it um I'd hate
to schedule it for the 20th and then
find that we have a session a day um
then we're in another pickle
um and we have one bill that is an early
bill which means March
6th um that has to be acted upon um and
and if we go to the 20th we would
still
need I'm inclined to go to the 12th um
is that going to is that going to mess
L depends how many Valentine's Day
dinners I
found
um well the 19th not an option Mr the
19th the
Wednesday
um do you have any anyone else have any
problem with the 19th it's only gaining
us a day but um but it would protect us
if a session day comes in I try well
here again it's hard to have everything
but I'm trying to not make it so that
for some people it's difficult for them
to take two days in one week and if they
do have a session and we have
um oh well maybe not I mean it we do
have um
we do have a small schedule so
um what do you think of that what do you
think of the 19th that work too and
that's not your no appointments that day
um is that part of can you look up uh
representative ral's schedule I think
that's outside that
too why don't we why don't we um why
don't we say that let's say the 19th and
then we're
then we're good and if we can tell Karen
that we'll make everything as the same
schedule um we'll do everything on the
19th okay so let's okay with that
everybody
19th um good
uh so here's this is probably a
appropriate time to start talking about
absences um we have I have one
um lifelong request um anything that you
are doing that affects the committee
please let either myself or Vanessa know
um if you're not going to be here let us
know um if you are um in the minority
side please let um our ranking member
know um we still have the same rule that
24 hours is necessary to replace you for
exact
sessions thank
you you need anything from us let us
know
okay
um and so um it's even things like
amendments um if there's an amendment
that you're working on on a specific
bill that we've heard let us know um the
the worst part of any of this is uh as
um representative wall will say is our
surprises um it's the it's the hardest
thing to deal with so if we know that
there there's an amendment coming in for
instance and it hasn't been completed
yet we can maybe adjust the schedule for
that um that exact session day or
something you know just let us know um
then even more mundane things we've got
um um things like a new we have a new
email address coming for everybody I I'm
assuming you are aware of all of that so
anybody that has business cards I think
that actually will work for the short
term but eventually um there will be a a
a.gov um email address um dress and
um I've always said in the past try to
make sure you give an appearance as if
your mother was watching and she would
be proud of you um so uh but that all
goes uh from from the waist up as far as
I'm concerned um I don't I don't think
it's a good idea to have pink fuzzy
slippers on underneath the counter but
no one would know um we uh we voted down
our um the the rule Chang to uh have
business attire but um both most every
everybody is looking pretty nicely today
so I mean this kind of thing we just
want to uh present the image that we are
Professional Organization so I'll leave
it at that you're all
professionals um food coffee
drink I prefer no food no drink on the
on the table um
yeah um it should be no food in the in
the committee room actually um it should
be um anything water is fine um but uh
but anything else there are little
shelves underneath here on the tables
that uh are a good place to put things
um I would uh I would prefer if someone
is
testifying um none of us are U are
grabbing our water bottles and uh and
um partaking so so um this is again kind
of uh an an office um and we want to
project that image
um oh I should have asked do you happen
to know whether we have um lockable
draws
anywhere um you know how all the other
committees have U drawers that are
assigned to each yeah I it suddenly
occurred to me this morning um I've
never used them but other people here do
um that are stack lockable drawers just
for you for our committee um because
we're sharing this room with
Transportation I think those ones that
are in there are just strictly
Transportation which means I have one
but I don't need it um but if if
necessary if people would appreciate
that um ability um I'll make make sure
that we have them either here or in our
office down on the first floor
um yeah so um room 104 down below here
um is uh how do I describe where that is
uh it's actually behind the ladies room
um on the in in the lobby area what' you
okay so so there's actually five because
I don't want mine um so if anybody wants
a lockable drawer here um you can have
one um please please see Karen I guess
yep questions no good um
um my suggestion is not to leave food in
those but um that's a another story I'll
tell you it another time not
online
um any medical issues please let me know
and uh and we can make accommodations I
have no requirements for seating um
generally I would like um uh for
security purposes for you to be near the
end
um if everybody is happy where they are
that's fine with me um if you want uh I
don't I you know some other chairs want
to make sure that there's alternating
Republicans and Democrats or all of them
on one side or the other I I don't care
you're you're professionals yep just to
follow up on on seating because um if
you recall I tend to come in at the very
last minute or sometimes late so if you
want to review what your prep ref es and
a protocol for that y um around
testimony and and things and and coming
into the committee room that be so um
testifying um if if you do come in uh as
always I prefer people get here on time
um prior to prior to testimony um I'm
usually right on the number um sometimes
within five minutes of afterwards but um
if you come in and someone is testified
I prefer you wait um until they have
completed their testimony and then you
move to your your chair um it's uh to me
a common courtesy thing likewise if you
have to leave um like the clerk does um
you um I would wait until uh or try to
time it so that uh if someone is done
testifying you get up and leave
obviously if there's an emergency a
medical emergency um just go um but uh
again this gets back to letting us know
what what to expect so if you have
perhaps a hearing that you have to
testify on um while we're in the middle
of hearings just let um the vice chair
or I know um that you'll be leaving at
such and such a
time um and then you know you would find
a time in while they're testifying while
people are coming in and out to testify
where you would get up and leave at the
time someone was leaving at the witness
table that's all um again it's just uh
letting us know what's going
on um use of electronic devices uh some
chairs are not a fan of us having um
electronic devices up and running while
um while people are testifying
I can understand that um but I also
understand the helpful nature there are
some people that like to take their
notes on on a pad um or um laptop I
would prefer it not
be
H I would prefer two things one that it
doesn't
block you from the person testifying I
don't I I don't want people to be hiding
behind it um and the second thing is I
don't want um a great big uh I don't
know Grateful Dead no that's not that's
not bad no um but I you know uh I hate
fossil fuels and you get the guys from
uh you
know something sitting on here that's
all if it's if you need to use it or you
want to use it I would have no problem
my only concern is I want to make sure
the people that take the time to come
here and
testify believe and understand that
their testimony is the most important
thing that's going on here so I don't
want to hear the candy crushed sound
when uh you know if there is such a
thing I don't even know um but it is it
is vital that we have people come
anticipate to us it is therefore only
common courtesy for us to give them our
full attention and then that goes
to the fact that uh if you have a
question about how their testimony is
going or or something a statement that
they made that that you want
clarified you come through the chair um
just generally what people do is just
get catch my eye and make sure that I
have a question or something along those
lines um I will call on you um and you
will ask your question we're not here to
debate we're not here to um disagree
with or or
um make it anything other than a
clarifying question um did I hear you
say um that this is this or can you
explain more fully what you meant by
this um that's fine if they still are
not answering your concern um you can
request a follow-up question to me and
and usually what people do is while
they're talking if it's clear they're
not understanding what your question is
they again catch my eye and they'll
they'll make a sybol like you know
followup I'd like to do that and I will
um Grant the followup so um but the key
thing is we are going to listen to
whatever they tell us um and not
um I have already spoken to
representative Boyd um
about in this day and age we need to
have someone that is keyed in as our
security person so if we have if we have
someone um that is is unruly and I'm I'm
telling you there's almost no chance in
this committee we have very few people
come and testify anyway but um but if
there's somebody that is unruly or
disruptive I will um ask them to control
themselves and if it appears to be
escalating um I will ask I would usually
my way of doing it is saying
Representative Steve can you go see if
um
um someone you know someone is available
the Representative Steve rather than
representative Boyd is the hint for you
know you need to go get someone and um
and so I'm going to ask that you know
either you make your way quietly off um
off stage and and get some assistance
the other Advantage we have is because
these are recorded and someone is
theoretically listening to these
somewhere else um they may on their way
already um so I may not even do that if
I'm certain that someone is already
listening um but that's we can have
other discussions about that fire
escapes um we're going to go out the
door and turn left and go all the way
down to the end of the hall and then
down and into the legislative parking
garage unless the fire is there then
we're going to go that way and you can
go either direction down those stairs
don't do the elev
right um what else we got uh committee
seating I'm okay I don't care um
currently we have 12 bills one early
bill um I've already mentioned that
subcommittees I'm not a fan um and
typically if we do have a bill that
needs work uh I will ask and do a
committee of the whole um doesn't happen
very often it did last term when we
worked on the ethics bill the recusal
bill um but it always seemed that we
were better off having that discussion
as an entire group rather than um a
small group trying to work on it and
then bringing in explaining what they're
doing it just made more sense to me as a
whole so I would do
that
um second committee work uh not an issue
because it's only Vanessa and I that are
on other committees so we don't have to
worry about that
um for your information though I learned
something um if if the second committee
is having you can p put this in your in
your list of things that you didn't know
um if the second committee is having an
exec session on the same
day I've always thought that because uh
you were in the building you couldn't be
replaced but apparently um we have a not
a rule we have a
practice that allows I'm looking for
nothing
oh okay so not that it's going to come
up but from for my purposes because
Vanessa is serving in um
Edna I was concerned that if they if we
schedule an exec session at the same
time here while she's in an exec session
there how are we going we were going to
lose uh a vote on this side because um
she would be in that and we couldn't
yep yeah well I don't like working it
out I like the ability to uh to just say
all right we'll have somebody else here
voting for that but I didn't know by the
way um we are also kenti we also are a
little unusual because we're probably
the only committee that has
three past chairs or past and current
chairs um in the committee so uh
representative wall uh has been chair
and representative turot has has also
been share so um there may be times
while I'll say what did I screw up what
can we do um or what um is there
something that I'm missing and I'm
counting on the two of you to jump in um
along with uh with our vice chair if uh
we get too far down a rabbit hole
somewhere along here just so you know
um committee Replacements uh minimum 24
hours you need to know that before and
and let your ranking member or or
Vanessa or I or the majority office
know uh I've already done all the public
hearing items there is a conflict of
interest in recusal as I mentioned we we
wrote it her names on it um so if you
have uh a conflict that you believe um
with any of the bills that were coming
up let us know and we'll help you with
that um no surprise amendments I said
that our bills are often times consent
um meaning that everybody is going the
same way on that um which is a good
thing uh most of our bills are well
known to us so that um I have no problem
reusing committee reports so if someone
makes the motion um of whatever itl to
pass whatever the motion happens to be
um we may already have the committee
report report pre-written so um that may
make it easier for somebody to make
those
motions uh I think that's all done
um we already talked about Jennifer
where she is she's up by the pool on the
fourth
floor
um internet access uh we're going to
deal with that um privately not
online and there is a computer um in our
office on the fourth floor if you need
that um let us know we'll make
sure you pretty much seem to have to
just get in room 104 our office is off
the back of room 104 and but that door
is usually unlocked right so um if you
need a computer in there let us know
there's a computer and printer
so
um what else um
we've already done where to stay when
the you're testifying somewhere else
um we may have
one um one bill that we end up working
on as a as a collective and it's the
lobbying bill um for those of you that
were on the committee last time we had
that bill last time and we ended up
amending it and then it
was um it was in it was indefinitely
postponed wasn't it
yes okay so it was indefinitely
postponed um I don't know if we're going
to go the same route um or whether we
are going
to um modify it in some way shape or
form but but the key thing is because it
is an early
bill um the reason it's an early bill is
it has um money attached to it uh
penalties or fees I forget now um and
and we are going to um without question
at least amend that part out which would
mean it wouldn't qualify at that point
as an early bill but we still need to
get it
done um and I asked uh representative
turot to almost make that his baby um so
U we are we are going to uh keep an eye
on that one
[Music]
um I think that's about all I have that
is important conflict recusal I've got
that committee reports um intended to be
clear concise summary of what happened
um couple of times I had
and I um I try not to change change what
you're intending but sometimes I have to
um I will always talk with you if we
need to do something with it um either
it it can't well we'll talk about it as
it comes along I guess you there there
are certain rules for committee reports
you can't just say you know the other
side are a bunch of idiots and this is
why we can't do this
um we have yeah go ahead you'll be this
suggest suggested AI for
the I am I am um but it also is not just
me um I have had a couple of times when
the speaker or the clerk has sent back
um a committee report and
said is this accurate or is this correct
and we have had to modify it um the one
thing that I do want to talk about and
and this will be the last thing
um this is true of the entire house from
the time that
we when when a bill comes in it becomes
ours right it's not it's no longer the
prime sponsors it's our bill at that
point this committee um from the time
that we vote on it and exec it and send
it into the calendar to the
house all the way from that point to the
point that it comes out of a committee
Senate we need to develop a way of of
still maintaining ownership of the work
that we've done in this committee so we
have coincidentally we have 12 bills we
have 12 members um but I think it would
be a good idea if we um use people's
talents to be able
to own this bill as it leaves here
whether that means um that person is
testifying on it or setting up someone
to testify at the house level Andor
whatever happens in the house
level um to be the person that also
introduces it in the Senate and explains
what we've done with this policy uh with
this um this bill and and why we did
what we did there has to be a way that
we don't just wash our hands of it and
say all right well we voted on it it's
in the calendar it's all yours um there
needs to be something someone some way
from this committee to be able to um
each own or or maybe we have one group
that owns it from that point on but I'm
open to suggestions um don't have to
come up with them now but if there's a
maintain ownership um um because it is
our bill as it comes out of this
committee and uh and we are the ones
that theoretically know more about the
subject matter than anyone else um so we
should be the ones that tell um the the
senate
committee why we did what we did agreed
or does that
work um I also don't want to yeah sure
with the just a follow-up question on
that so in that role for example if we
pull the thread all the way through that
would that person representing that
would
almost um provide a synopsis but of both
sides of the discussion that would be
something that I think as committee
members we should kind of pledge to each
other that there would be what the
majority vote was and what we knew but
also the part that there should
be maybe not equal but
a mention of the minority because that
gives the fullest picture of what
happened in the room I just so I think
this gets back to that communication
idea um and first off as I mentioned
most of our bills are consent um so
there is that but um but there's nothing
wrong
with um either the both the person that
if there is a minority blurb for
instance um which is a committee report
I'm sorry I keep reverting back to that
old vernacular um but if there is both
then um there's nothing wrong with
saying to um the minority person I
intend to go to the Senate and testify
on what the majority position is if if
you want to come as well and explain the
other side you know have at it um uh
otherwise
you're right I mean there there's always
not always but there's two sides to a
story sometimes um keep in mind that
there's
probably you're almost I'm looking at it
as you're almost replacing the prime
sponsor of the bill if we are amending
it in this in this committee so um I
don't know I I'm I'm open the
suggestions
it's still our bill at that point I mean
yes I mean it may be that the prime
sponsor would still be at the Senate
hearing but we are too um and it is and
our our ownership I there may be a much
lesser role if the bill goes through or
um exactly the way it was originally
written but
um I don't know I'm just looking for a
way to still be attached to um our bill
when it's at the Senate same thing is
when it comes out of the Senate you
typically see one of the Senators um
that will come and it's not always the
um the senator that wrote it um someone
from the Senate will come and talk on
one of their bills same thing but um
anyway that's just I always look for a
way to to pass it along
yeah for followup I tend to look at how
implementation of this might work I like
the idea but once this starts to happen
this afternoon in our discussion it
moves out of here potentially or at
least by the end of the month are you
then looking
for individuals to
volunteer in the same way that we have
that discussion at the end of the Bill
of who's writing the
um so part of the other conversation is
whether we are going to ever get into a
situation where a bill either gets
pulled off consent and and who is going
to
um you all right tickle yeah um who is
ever going to
um um Express the committee point
generally
um I mean we have we have to have
someone named from the committee on
every um on every bill just in case
something somebody pulls something off
or um so whether that is the person that
wrote the blur or I I fully understand
that there are people that don't want to
go to the floor and talk on things I
also understand that some of our bills
are great learning experiences for you
to do that um
so um I think we have to be flexible on
that who who is doing what um but if
there's something that you feel strongly
about
um let one of us know that I would like
to speak on the floor or not speak on
the
floor that answer what you were saying
or no yeah I I don't have I don't think
I have a definitive answer for you I
think it is a case by casee basis and we
only have 12 of them so um it's kind of
simple it's not like we have 80 bills
and we have to divide up you know 15 of
them to everyone anyway that's I think
I'll leave it from there if you have
suggestions and as we get to a bill I
may you know whoever makes the motion
I'll say you know is there going to or
or whoever votes in the minority is
there a minority BL and do you intend
to um bring up the minority point of
view on the floor and then whatever
happens with it there's too many options
at that point you know whether it gets
amended on the floor who owns it all of
those things so I don't know how we
would ever get
there I think that's all I have
um unless somebody has you have ideas of
what else we didn't touch on that we
should have um
um no yes yep um we you started talking
about having people kind of introduce
themselves kind of like to Sure know
about everybody here um why don't you
start I'd like to go I'd like to go last
no I don't I don't really care that's
fine uh represent Len turot uh other
than in professional situations I go by
Len not representative turot um fifth
term uh first two terms I served on
labor first one with representative Hill
on my third term I was on labor Finance
redistricting and Senior advisor in the
majority office last term uh chair of
Municipal and County this term I
requested no committee um until
representative Hill called me and said
would you mind being on legi admin and I
said since it's a light committee I
would uh love to do that so and I came
through with that I only have 12 bills
right I mean my AP
Steve Boyd hooks at
dun what other committee you also served
on labor for a while I'm on uh this is
my third term I've been on labor and
Edna and why not on those now because
this is a light load here and you ask me
specifically to be on your committee you
theme uh Carrie senson I represent
psmith this is my first term
um which is unusual in this committee by
the way um up until last year this used
to be um you know you had to I was not
sure when I asked for this committee
whether I would qualify because I had
only five terms at that point um it used
to be you were and and it used to be
populated with the um the speaker the
majority leader the um you know Deputy
something it used to oh yeah I'm getting
nodding from it used to be um almost
like rules committee that you you were
here for a while and knew how the
legislature operated for a good reason I
think but last term I think we ended up
with six six freshman um so you're not
breaking ground but um it is unusual I'm
sorry to interrupt that's okay um why
did you pick legislative Administration
yeah thank you uh it's my first term so
I just thought it' be a good place to
get to learn how things work plus I work
full-time and I'm a new mother so
sometimes my daughter might be coming
okay Beth Richards um and I this is my
fifth term um I think I mentioned this
is my third term in here and with L
admin and Report was environment and
culture I wasn't conquered um so you may
see me
walking your
businesses and I have a a a business
that is um in hopkington now it had been
in conquered um uh but it is a corner
store uh if you're familiar and drove on
202 in Main Street in hopkington it was
always it was the CRA old Cracker Barrel
um and so I feed people um and uh and do
fun things there so I love
that yeah so what so I can if we take
lunch orders at some time morning I can
go out and pick it up and I we can bring
in BLTs and soups and things like that
I'm I'm not um averse to to doing to
doing that excellent
thanks hi everyone I'm Alice way I'm
also a first term rep um from do W 2 and
my full-time job is as an aerospace
engineer um this is the same yeah yeah
it seems seems pretty
similar but yeah so you know this is
another
Aerospace but on the on the other end
he's he's not designing he's flying so
gotcha um yeah I just uh recently
graduated from UNH and I chose
legislative Administration since
a it was lower workload but also I was
interested in in helping work on some of
the issues that made it hard for a
working person to be a legislator oh I
see so that's that's one of the reason
we have those we have those bills um I
don't think there is one there's one
this afternoon there is yeah okay yeah I
haven't read them yet no I'm kidding uh
thank you for
coming hello uh my Stephanie P I
represent hener um Warner and Bradford
this is my second term and my second
time on legi admin and I requested legi
admin
so because I heard you were the chair
surprised this yeah so um I also work
full-time uh I'm an administrator at
chesher Medical Center so this uh
committee I I can be on a committee but
it's not overwhelming with the time
commitment so I like that I just uh
so I have been mispronouncing your name
all these years no you can say either
way P or P it doesn't matter okay yeah I
I was going to apologize but I guess
no
Janet
um something I you said that that
trigger a question and now it's gone um
yeah um you'll notice that that another
part of the scheduling that we've always
tried to do these are these are um
temporary walls that come in so if they
happen to be in in session at the same
time it can get loud um for a while we
were working in double rooms and it was
much better I thought but uh but these
these can get loud so uh I apologize for
that in advance can't remember what it
is I was going to ask you
um doesn't matter it'll come
back
Vanessa I'm representative Vanessa she
and um chairman Hill already kind of
introduced me and told you some of my
history but this is my third term in the
legislature this is my third term here
on ledge admin and I'm looking forward
to the the
term um I think I did I already say what
I am I am I've been here since 2010
um uh nothing else I guess um I've been
on a whole bunch of other committees um
I try to use our time efficiently that's
my goal um so I apologize in advance if
there's things that I'll do that um that
don't fit your particular schedule but
I'm trying to get everybody um as close
to U being uniform as we can we do have
two additional members um one that
you'll meet this afternoon for the
hearing at 1 um and the who you probably
don't is he a
freshman um representative Barton yes he
is okay um so I have not met him either
but um representative Barton is the
Freshman he'll be here at one and
representative verville is the other um
he is I don't know five terms maybe
that right right um he too opted out of
being um having a committee I think and
uh and just when he thought he was out
we dragged him back in but um he is uh
um because of work he has difficulty
making times um and I as I mentioned
earlier he's out for the last week of
traveling uh for his business um so um
he'll he'll be in and out but he's
always an active grou member um anything
else that uh we need to
do see what happens with scheduling um
so our hearing is at 1 um if there's
anything
now and the and the downside of that
is
um we um if I'll be here probably for a
half hour or so if there are things that
people privately want to discuss with
Vanessa or I um you know may maybe there
are issues that that want want need
personal attention um other than that um
we have a hearing beginning at
1 I don't see any reason that we won't
be done by two but uh I'm often wrong as
I uh as I have announced already
um with that I'm happy to close the
orientation and move oh yes represent
our
wall that's up to them you're you're
going to have to figure that out um I
again
e
the time being
1:00 I am going to I'm inclined unless
there's something that's come up in the
interum um from anyone um I want first
of all to um introduce and welcome um
our representative Joe Barton um who you
want to tell us a little bit about
yourself quickly here so that uh
everyone else has gone around the room
and explained who they are and why they
are in legislative Administration if you
want to take
know
okay yeah sorry about that um
let's see I I grew up in Lancaster New
Hampshire I worked for the shipyard in
um in Portsmith for 16 years and uh just
u a few years ago moved to uh Littleton
um to be closer to where I I grew up I'm
an engineer I do a lot of other things
I'm a pilot um and uh I I was hatched
for many years working for the shipyard
and now I work in the in the private
sector and have a flexible work schedule
so uh I ran for office
here I am thank you very much the one
thing that came up that you'll probably
want to put on your schedule is we our
next batch of hearings um we had to move
because uh the governor's budget hearing
is that day so um it will not be the
Wednesday uh with that um I'll open the
hearing on House Bill
uh 118 uh welcome the prime sponsor
representative Thomas welcome to
legislative
Administration thank you very much Mr
chair and members of the committee I
think this is my first time in front of
you guys um so it's an honor thank you
appreciate it I am Wendy Thomas and I
represent the town of marac I'm here to
introduce House Bill 118 which is an act
establishing required breaks during
legislative
proceedings allowing a 10-minute break
after three-hour continuous legislative
session would be highly beneficial
beneficial to older employed parent and
caretaker legislators for several
reasons older legislators may experience
physical discomfort fatigue or strain
from sitting for extended periods a
short break provides an opportunity to
stand stretch and move around helping to
prevent issues like stiffness poor
circulation blood clots or back pain
that can arise from prolonged sitting
this is crucial for maintaining
long-term health and preventing burnout
especially for older individuals who may
be V more vulnerable to these physical
stresses legislative work often requires
intense focus and critical thinking a
break even if brief can help reset the
Mind reduce cognitive fatigue and
enhance concentration for older
legislators who may face age related
cognitive decline taking breaks helps
maintain mental sharpness and effective
Ness in making decisions parents and
caretakers often have multiple
responsibilities outside of their
legislative duties a 10-minute break
provides a much needed moment to check
in on Family Matters ensure children or
dependents are being cared for or handle
any urgent personal tasks this brief
respit allows them to fulfill their
responsibilities at home while still
staying engaged in the legislative
process legislators with jobs outside of
their legisl duties often have to juggle
me multiple tasks including work family
obligations and Civic duties a brief
break gives them time to quickly address
any personal matters check in with their
job responsibilities or handle any
pressing work related Communications
helping them to stay on top of both
their job and legislative duties without
feeling
overwhelmed it is our role as elected
officials to emulate the behavior we
wish to see in others if a constituent
contacted me and told me that her
employer demanded she worked 7 hours
straight without a bathroom break or any
kind of break you can be sure that I
would look into that
situation House Bill 96 uh I'm sorry
house house bill 118 is a bill that
gives legislators dignity and health
protections while we do our job at the
State House in conclusion allowing a
10-minute break every three hours of
continuous legislative work supports the
well-being mental Al focus and personal
responsibility of older employed parents
and caregivers um who are all
legislators enabling us all to
contribute effectively while maintaining
a healthy work life balance I'm happy to
take any questions thank you uh first
question is uh is that written testimony
you'd like to submit I certainly can do
that it needs to be edited but I can get
it to your box this afternoon okay be
great yeah for our Clerk um second
question you you mentioned that you
would be willing to take
questions correct yeah are there any
questions for the prime
sponsor representative
Bon what's what's the present
practice the present practice is we come
back after lunch which is approximately
1 o'clock and sometimes we can go to 4 5
6 7:00 at night sometimes even later
with non no stop no break at all and um
I follow up you will ask for yeah if I
if I can follow up um if someone needed
to to take a break or use the bathroom
could they not request from the chair to
break I don't think that's I've ever
heard of that happening and but this is
also for the floor um in when we have
session so I don't think you can ask the
person I would I would follow up with if
if a member needed to use the bathroom
during session what would that member do
so I'm glad you brought that up because
this is something that we have discussed
what we do is we figure out the people
that that speak longer and we sort of
time it so that we are using the
bathroom um when these people who who
typically speak longer go forcing us to
not do our job because we can't hear
that person speak while we're while
we're using the bathroom or checking in
on our kids at home or checking in at
work so this is not just the bathroom we
also have some older Representatives who
uh use uh incontinence pads and this
would allow them the dignity to to
change their pad on a regular basis or
something um it would just give everyone
a break a a deserved
break thank you any further
questions I have one oh sure um do I
understand that uh you're saying um
someone has asked for from the chair or
um or anyone else I can understand the
the floor being different um but asked
for um a break in in a committee room
and been not given it I am I
I have no experience with that I've
never seen that in my committee um I've
not heard of it happening in other
committees so I I can't I can't really
say for sure I've just I've never seen
that I've never seen a session being I
mean a a session being stopped like that
um yes um like chairman
she um has there ever been a time where
a session has has gone on for seven
hours straight where no break was taken
because if I recall the speaker
um had to provide a lunch break if we I
mean an evening supper break if we went
past six o'clock I
believe
um
I I think the clerk might be able to
me um however if we have a dinner break
that's typically at 5 or 6 we still come
from from after launch to 5 or 6 without
a
break
non-stop yes um is there anything that
would uh prohibit a member either in
committee or on the floor um from making
a motion for a brief recess
and getting a a vote of the membership
instead of mandator it m making it
mandatory in
law I don't believe I have the answer to
[Music]
probably thank you Mr chairman
I thank you I appreciate it um I'll be
brief uh I just wanted to give uh some
testimony uh to back this up um the
reason I would find it really helpful um
in legislative sessions particularly is
because last year last term I underwent
two knee surgeries um in which case I
was either in a wheelchair or on
crutches I don't know if you guys if any
of you have had the chance to walk from
section four or or crutch or wheelchair
from section four all the way to the
women's bathroom and then all the way
back to your seat while worrying about
missing any testimony missing any um any
hearings or or any anything that we
needed to be hearing um but it is
certainly very scary um at times because
I worried that I'd miss a vote I'd miss
a roll call um and in my incapacitated
state it was very difficult to get back
in the allotted um time of the speaker
and know when the speaker would start or
stop um it is quite a long walk
questions yes representative W um I
don't know if you might have the answer
to this but um do you know if there's a
reason that this was brought as a House
Bill rather than a rule
necessarily sorry that might I don't
know I could I could possibly refer to
the prime sponsor uh representative
Thomas um but I don't personally
know she can come back up after we're
done with representative
Lloyd any further questions yes thank
you Mr chairman thank you for your
testimony I hadn't thought of it that
way although I've been position um is
there anything to stop this from being
in house
rules again I would have to refer to the
prime um sponsor thank um I have this I
heard about this uh this legislation um
a little while ago so I just wanted to
make sure that I gave my assessment of
how difficult it was last term for me
personally thank you any further
questions representative Bon
would um would there be anything that
would prohibit a member from making a
request of the speaker um or the the
chairman in cases of of committee
meetings for reasonable accommodation to
uh for for a reassignment of a seat or a
temporary seat that's closer to the
bathroom sure um I appreciate that
question um so as it stands right now
because of our assigned seats we're
typically uh anybody reassigned to
um a a seat needing extra Services I
believe the clerk might actually be able
to answer this better but um we were put
kind of at the back of um of the house
floor either in the chairs or um when I
was in a wheelchair it was kind of
behind section four um and uh in order
to make a motion I would have had to get
myself down to the podium to make that
motion um either via whe chair and have
someone push me or um or crutch all the
way down there um potentially like
interrupting some legislation um and
causing some concern and or just simple
embarrassment um of having to ask for a
bathroom break for myself specifically
um and that weighs a lot on me because I
do not want to impede the legislative um
process from happening because I
personally need to go to the bathroom um
so I I would follow up um Mr chairman
would um you will I I will I'll Grant
you the
followup thank you very much um uh I'm
gonna restate my question if I I didn't
state it properly uh my question was is
there anything prohibiting a member from
making a request of the speaker or the
chairman outside of session or outside
of committee for the accommodation
um it would it would still require the I
believe the best way I could answer that
is it would still require the speaker to
pause the H the general court session in
order to allow for that type of a break
and to ask for that for one person on
the house floor it would be really
difficult despite the fact that there
may be other people who would also need
to go at that point in time um but it is
very difficult to have one member
stand up and say can we request a motion
there it has been done a couple of times
on lengthy um lengthy uh session days I
believe but um it again you have to
basically judge it within yourself to
say I really really really need to go
and that's a bit
embarrassing thank you one one more
followup sure um sure last quickly um I
uh I I guess
is there anything prohibiting a member
from making that request outside of
session or committee or must the request
be made during I would have sorry um I
didn't mean to jump the gun there but um
I would have to know ahead of time what
specific breaks I would need and when I
would need them um sometimes it was just
to take pain meds um so that I was not
taking pain meds on the house floor
sometimes it was to get to the bathroom
um but if I knew a ahead of time that if
there was a
three-hour break or the three-hour
session and then there would be a break
I could um I I'm sure manage to get to
that three-hour
Mark okay thank you very much for your
testimony uh there was one question if
um representative Thomas wants to do her
best with a quick answer that would be
great thank you Mr chair I intend to do
my best um that that actually is a
question that has come up why wasn't
this introduced as a rule as opposed to
a bill um and the reason is that we know
from previous experience that rules can
be overturned by the party that is in
the majority this is not something that
should ever be overturned this is a
protection that should be permanent for
all legislators going
forward you're welcome thank
you uh I have no other pink cards um I
don't know if the clerk would like to
chime in on anything that was brought up
um um we we can discuss that in in exec
session if we need to um seeing no other
pink cards um I will close the hearing
on uh House Bill 118 and uh just a brief
time to reset um like the new the new
tag on the on the witness table um we'll
the time being 1:40 I'll open the
hearing on uh House Bill 347 recognize
the prime sponsor um representative
back I think that was the briefest break
I have possibly had in a while um thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for
hearing me um I'll try to be as brief as
possible I was before this committee
last term uh with this basically
identical bill um the the reason I am
submitting this as a bill um it possibly
got lost last term um I gave a a brief
description of my personal experience
and why this was an issue um in which
case I had an employer who um agreed at
the onset that I could go ahead and do
legislative Ser like my legislative
tasks and duties and attend session days
um however at one point it just became
untenable to them and so they decided
that I could not attend legislative
sessions and prohibited me from doing so
um which then basically led to me
needing to schedule um a a break in
order to do my legislative Duty um this
particular bill would set up a leave of
absence policy basically essentially um
it keeps coming to ledge admin because
it has to do with our job but
technically it's kind of more of an
employment protection um for folks who
are needing to work um and also needing
to attend legislative sessions it's just
for house session days when we are it's
mandatory that we're there it is not
meant for committee work it's not meant
for any type of meetings or um any type
of
uh things that we need to do for
campaigning any of that type of stuff it
specifically is for days when we are
required to be in our seat for our vote
to be counted um last term when I was
looking into this legislation the
biggest concern that I found when I was
considering it is um the fact
that our house calendar is publicized
which is fine that's that's the way it
should be the public should know what
we're voting on in on certain days but
my biggest concern here is that if we
had a closely tied session like we had
last term um an employer could see what
is on the docket and basically tell
their employee no you can't go and then
that puts that particular rep in a
position of deciding whether or not they
can continue their job um or if they
disregard their employer and come in and
vote anyway in legislative session um we
did have one uh one rep testify that she
felt her employer had done that last
term um so or they testified last term
but it was in a prior um term that they
felt their employer had done that so I
thought about it and I was like what can
we do in order to protect our
legislative duties here um and make sure
that those are prioritized over any type
of um employment that we have outside of
the state because we are representing
our people and I hold that very very
high um in my regard
um I didn't want to submit any type of a
bill or legislation to increase payments
to us because I don't feel like that
should be passed down to the taxpayer um
and this was the best thing that I could
think of that would not cause any type
of um an increase in our salary but it
would still allow us to do what we
needed to do on the days that we needed
to do it for the session dates that
didn't have anything except for
mandatory atten
um I've been working in nonprofit for 18
plus years I don't know of any other
organization that says this is volunteer
work and it's okay for you to volunteer
and potentially lose your job um I have
been working in payroll and and Human
Resources all of those years I will say
that in the past I'd say five or so
years I have seen an increase in
employers requiring some sort of
documentation in order to allow a
variance to their employment policies
right now a lot of employers have a
policy in place where it states that you
can be absent for up to three days
before you have to have a doctor's note
um it is very diff I foresee a point in
time where we will get uh to questioning
why we need this many days or this many
hours um to be at the state house and I
foresee any issues um or I foresee a lot
of issues around that so that's why I
had come up with this it kind of sets it
up like jury duty um where the employer
does not need to pay the employee for
that time off all they need to do is
understand that those session days are
guaranteed to that legislator so that
they can be there to fulfill their
legislative
Duty um
so that is that piece of it I'm open to
any question
thank you for your testimony um are
there questions for representative
Lloyd yes representative
weight uh yes thank you Mr chair um so
how did you end up arriving or
calculating the specific 168 hours sure
um so that that piece of things I'm open
to change the number of hours I came up
with it by looking at how many days we
were asked to reserve off in the 2020 to
legislative calendar and then
multiplying that by eight hours um per
day uh so that that way I could come up
with some sort of number um I would like
to do a review of the number of days
that we've actually been called into
session and potentially come up with a
better average um I would be open to um
changing that number slightly but it is
quite a number of hours and so I wanted
to cap it off so that it was not too
much of a burden on employer
2022 thank you um and then how would
this function for out of state employers
as well compared to New Hampshire
employers sure um so technically I I
would not necessarily benefit directly
from this uh change because I work in
Massachusetts in my 9 to5 job uh this
would I foresee this happening for New
Hampshire employers um because we can't
really legislate for I would love to see
this go Federal that would be great but
uh we can't legislate for employers that
are beyond our state borders however
what I foresee this doing is allowing
people like myself who may work in other
states to have at least an argument to
bring to their employer and say in New
Hampshire they're required to do this so
it it would be beneficial if I could get
into um get to do what I need to do
thank you that's all for me further
questions represent s thank you chairman
um so do you have an idea of how many
employees an employer has to have before
this Tak effect I did not put a minimum
employee requirement in there however um
it's not that I wouldn't be amable to
doing that it I did put a hardship
clause in there and I tried to keep the
legislation as efficient as possible um
by not including redundant pieces of
material so basically if an employer had
a hardship because they have too few
employees or if they had an employee who
was um the only person serving in that
particular department they would be able
Exempted no further comment I I have one
sure um so in that instance that you're
talking about uh that they would claim a
hardship um actually it's a two-part
question who would they claim that too
um is that someone like the house Clerk
or is that someone like uh the
Department of Labor and and the second
part of the question is
um what if it's or or is that able to be
um denied or um what what happens if if
they refuse to do that that is the piece
that I would really um like to dig into
more with um ideally I was hoping this
would kind of go to the um labor and
Industrial um offices because they tend
to deal with leave of absences and those
types of of uh legisla legislative
requirements um but I believe it I mean
we have a process already for jury duty
exemptions um I don't know who uh who
exempts for jury duty um but I would
assume it would follow a similar
process okay um any further questions
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony um I have only one other pink
card uh for this um and it happens to be
from uh the Department of Labor um chair
calls uh John
garion who is neutral on Bill thank you
thank you chair members of the committee
my name is John garan I am general
counsel with the Department of Labor uh
the department is neutral on the bill
I'm just here today to provide some
technical guidance and procedural
information specifically about section
five uh of the bill um RSA
2731 11a uh that's the general penalty
provision that the Department of Labor
relies on when it's enforcing labor laws
um the way that works is uh a first time
violation um there's a statut
requirement that the commissioner
provide a warning to the employer and
then the employer has 30 days to cure or
correct um whatever violative condition
there is any subsequent violations would
be subject to a penalty of up to
$2,500
um one note um that we saw when
reviewing this bill is while RSA 2731
11a provides a penalty it does not not
kind of in and of itself provide a
jurisdiction or authorization for the
Department to engage in any sort of
Investigation um if the committee's
intent was to have uh the department
investigate the situations and then
bring enforcement actions um that our
suggestion would be to um amend the
language to add um a either
authorization within the bill itself or
to amend either one of the provisions of
RSA 273 or perhaps RSA 275 to allow for
that and the department is happy to work
with the committee on actual kind of
recommended language to achieve that
effect but that I'm happy to take
questions thank you for your testimony
there uh representative
turot thank you Mr chairman thanks for
taking the question uh does the
Department of Labor have jurisdiction
outside of the State of New Hampshire no
thank
you any further questions so so I will
piggyback on that
um Would we not be setting up a
situation where um non domestic um
employers would be treated differently
than International or or out of state
companies um there could be times where
there are employers that operate in
multiple States including New Hampshire
we would certainly have uh jurisdiction
over those types of employers but uh If
an employer operated solely outside of
the state or solely on an international
basis we would not have jurisdiction
over them so there could be times where
under this the commissioner could impose
penalties against certain companies but
not others
yeah thank you um further
questions seeing none thank you very
much for your
testimony um I have again no
further pink cards um anyone else
wanting to speak seeing none I'll close
the hearing
on what was that
347 thank you um actually we're right on
time if we want to uh reset the banner
uh we'll be ready to go
shortly while I have a quick second
though um you missed a couple of pieces
from this morning's um orientation one
one is um we ask for no drink or food on
the on the table um there is a little uh
shelf underneath on the underneath the
table here that uh they keep there um
the other part is um the procedure for
um questions of the of the um people
coming and giving us testimony so
typically um the one thing that is
mandatory is we are um and not casting
aspersions here but we are here to get
information from them um we are um in no
way going to try to um uh qu question
them like you would see on uh on out of
the any of the Committees in Washington
you know where um and we are trying to
just understand what information they
are trying to Pro provide to us we are
looking for clar ifying questions
basically um and the procedure is um if
they are answering a question either
that you didn't ask um or not answering
your question um during their testimony
you would look over ask for a followup
with a and Signal or something like that
and then I will ask if you have a
followup and then and then we go from
we don't have
um 315
who oh um do you want to just introduce
it for PR of this we have we have
it
do it's like deja vu all over again
right
time being 1:30 um the chair will open
up U the U public hearing on House Bill
315 not seeing the prime sponsor I'll
ask uh Vice chair shien if she will
introduce the bill VI Vice chair CH
thank you Mr chair um I'm representative
Vanessa Shen I represent
Hillsboro uh County uh District 43 the
town of Milford and I'd like to
introduce House Bill
315 uh thank you I'm I'm assuming no
questions I won't be taking any
questions today thank you thought
thought not um thank you very much um we
have uh two pink cards um I'm taking
them in the order that they arrived um
so the chair will call John John
Williams uh from
DHHS um who indicates no preference no
support or opposition to the bill um
providing information less than three
minutes chairman Hill and members of the
legislative Administration committee for
the record my name is John Williams I'm
the legislative director for Health and
Human Services and I am here on behalf
of the department um the department has
serious concerns with HB 315
uh as you see from the proposed
legislation uh it amends RSA 17 D3 uh
dealing with legislative investigations
and most specifically found on lines 10
through 14 if an employee it states if
an employee of a state agency knowingly
provides false information before the
committee he or she shall be prohibited
from testifying before the committee and
liable for purgy under RSA 641 colon 1
or FAL saring under RSA 64 1 colon 2 and
tampering with Witnesses and informant
under RSA
6415 uh it also amends the statute
involving stated employees appearing
before the legislature uh and it
requires us to wearing our
identification badges this was a law
that was created back in 2005 because of
transparency in government it was
important to know who is coming before
the legislative committees you'll see I
honor this every occasion I don't think
uh on any exception I've been without it
uh my landyard might have broke but my
card was always still there um passage
of the um bill would create a chilling
effect for state employees including
those at the department to communicate
with the legislature to provide you with
the important information needed for you
to develop State
policy um respecting the Constitutional
doctrine of separations of power and for
those of you who I've testified before I
I honor that um like you do I we all
taken an oath at some point I did as an
attorney when I swore into the Barb New
Hampshire to hold the constitution of
the state and the United States of
America as well and we do respect that
but it's also understood that the
branches of government work best and
most efficiently when they communicate
effectively between each other whether
it's the now legislative branch
communicating with the digital Branch or
the executive branch communicating with
the judicial branch or our branch of
government the executive branch
communicating with you and you more
importantly communicating back with us
in the development of really good policy
and and
legislation um with that um said uh
there's already in place um the for both
branches of government under the um um
for legislator and to the executive
branch agencies for for um uh the Ethics
Committee so if there is an occasion
where there's any impropriety whether
it's a conflict of interest or um other
uh improprieties before this body there
is a remedy to go before at least in our
occasion the ethics the legislative
executive branch Ethics Committee
there's a very formal process they swear
uh Witnesses in and they adjudicate
those matters when they come before them
also in addition to that for uh folks
like myself who are licensed I am an
active member of the New Hampshire bar
although my current role before you now
is as legislative director that I'm also
accountable to the New Hampshire Bar
Association for what I do before this
committee and cander towards this
committee is as important as cander
towards a tribunal and in a court and we
take that very very seriously when we
come before the legislature HB 1315
singles out only the executive branch
government it doesn't uh focus on the
legislative branch the judicial branch
or any other individuals who come before
this
committee um I'm just going to get to
the point because I'm keeping to that
three minute time repres Hill uh
chairman Hill uh here and I will be
providing you with a copy of my bulleted
uh testimony but the New Hampshire
tradition is one of transparency of
government and working together with you
and providing a law that would create a
criminal offense or at least the
possibility of being accused of a
criminal offense would create a chilling
effect for that very positive
communication that happens New Hampshire
does it right we have it right and there
are already checks and balances in the
process in the system to ensure the
Integrity of that process this bill is
not only need not needed but it would go
completely opposite of the way we do
things here in New Hampshire and with
that chairman Hill I'm available to
answer questions from the committee I'm
here today on behalf of the Department
of Health services but I would represent
to you this is obviously a concern to
many other state agencies within uh our
state government thank you very much for
your testimony
questions I have one um you mentioned uh
the Ethics Committee and and that being
a viable process for handling situations
like this has that ever been done to
your knowledge I would have well
fortunately for me I've not been before
the Ethics Committee so I don't have was
accusing you of anything personal
knowledge of that uh but I do believe
that that's handled through the
Department of Justice and certainly you
could inquire uh through your legal
council a wonderful attorney general for
and I'm happy to provide her with
contact information for more detail but
if you look to the actual RSA the
statute it's very very specific in terms
of the process uh the oath uh bringing
Witnesses and uh very very clear that
it's to prevent the types of things that
this legislation reportedly would be
trying to prevent
thank you very much for your testimony
no thank you all set I think um I have
uh one other pin card on this bill House
Bill 315 um from uh commissioner
Jasper welcome uh to leg I think you've
been in this room once or twice before
just a few but I I wanted to point out
that I specifically said that I'm
representing myself right um and I'm
that's why I'm not wearing a badge and
part of this is to point out the flaw in
this bill which there are many hopefully
you you've seen
um and what I want to point out this
talks in the first section in lines uh
11 through 14 talks about false swearing
and tampering with
Witnesses and informance I certainly
don't understand how that would
apply um there's nothing in here that
talks about anyone being sworn in but it
would appear that
um state employees would be held to that
standard without actually having taken
an oath uh I think that's problematic
and there's also a lack of due process
in both sections of this and that uh it
just knowingly is a very high
standard and but there is no due process
in this as to who makes the
determination what the judicial process
is this would appear to just say well
committee can just decide that can
somebody has appeared and um knowingly
done that well knowingly is a standard
that um is extremely hard to meet I mean
literally you would have to I believe
have
a person on taper and a written document
that contradicted the information that
he or she provided to the committee um
just believing that somebody knew that
they were providing information is not a
standard that you could hold anyone to
um so I think that um really I just want
to say that I hope you look at this very
carefully and understand that this is
not something that
um should be done or probably could be
done uh because of the the issue of
constitutional rights and again I'm here
as a private citizen now I will tell you
that the governor knows that I'm here
today but I'm still I also informed the
governor that I is coming as a private
citizen um so what would you do in a
situation like that attempt to take away
the rights of a private citizen to come
and testify and the first part is really
not about public hearings it's about
investigations um the second is about um
hearings and testimony and um again you
know to take away the ability for
someone to come in and oppose or support
a bill I think
what I almost forgot to tell you is when
I first read this bill the first thing I
thought of was the three monkeys See No
Evil Hear no evil speak no
evil that you know somebody clearly
doesn't want to have all the information
that would be out there and so I hope
you find this bill in expedient to
legislate I'm glad to take any questions
thank you um are there any Comm any
questions for uh private citizen um
Jasper
I have one um if I can ask you to draw
on your experiences as a speaker um if
it were a chair that U that asked for a
meeting with the speaker and and asked
um that in the future the speaker would
um communicate to the executive branch
Andor the commissioner um that they
would uh request a a different Lea on
from a um an agency um would that be
permissible I think it would be
permissible and um I certainly would
have no problem with with that and it
also um makes me think of a couple of
incidents on the the house house floor
when I was presiding and I knew that
members were saying things that were not
true and demonstrably so I interrupted
those members and pointed that out and
did not let them to continue and I think
it's within the purview of a committee
to challenge someone who is providing
testimony which you believe not to be
true but I don't think that we can then
take away that person's right to to ever
testify or come forward but I I think
that we absolutely have a duty to
challenge things that we believe and
could provide evidence of being
false thank you for your testimony um
any further questions seeing none thank
you very much we'll see you in a few
minutes I think um I would ask um
um John Williams um if he would also uh
chime in on that um that comment of of
whether it would be all right um for or
what would happen um in the situation
from a legal standpoint at at DHHS if uh
if uh you received a a notice from the
speaker or through the governor's office
that uh such and such a committee has
had requested to have a a different Lia
on to a committee is that is that
something that's ever done or Endor
would that ever be accepted or taken in
the spirit that it was intended so
drawing on my memory from doing this
closely going on Two and a Half decades
now doing legislative work before this
body I I've not received such a request
um for not having a particular
individual coming before committee but
what I can um express to you is we're
very thoughtful in terms of making sure
we have the right staff um if staff
comes before a committee that doesn't
know the subject matter they shouldn't
be before you and I've had concerns
raised in the past and we then worked
harder to make sure we got the right
people in front of the committee but it
wasn't such a formal request of saying
we shall not want to see that person
ever again before our our committee I I
think there might be some Personnel
rules that might be at play for us to
telling somebody they can't come and do
their job but I'm not prepared today to
get into all the legalities regarding
that and I'm looking for um our
wonderful person for the Department of
Labor maybe he can chime in on on that
as I'm going down a slippery slope of
knowledge that I don't have a great deal
subject matter knowledge of um but I do
think that state agencies are very
receptive they they hear you when you
say wonderful things about us we we love
that and when you say things that are of
concern we you have our total attention
we want to address those concerns very
meaningfully uh and if it's a particular
individual coming for a committee uh
that you feel has been less than either
transparent or doesn't know their um
subject matter we would work to address
those issues thank you for your answer
um it would also not preclude that
person from coming and testifying as an
individual as well right I would agree
with that and also with commissioner
Jasper's uh um thoughts as well on that
subject thank you very much you're
welcome um any further comments seeing
none um we do have a pin card um from
the prime sponsor and since I have not
closed the hearing um I will accept uh
the prime sponsor for coming in speaking
315 representative
Penza yes
minutes thank you Mr chair um sorry I'm
late there was two two huge big
Lumbertown trucks in front of me and
they were caused me to be late so um I
know that somebody already introduced
the bill um I think we're reading into
the bill a lot more than um than we
should I also there was an amendment I'm
not sure if it was passed out or not um
that just changes the bill so it
actually says before any house committee
not just the committee um So currently
everyone that is coming in front of um
to testify in front of the legislature
it's a known fact that it they are
coming in providing um truthful
testimony so there doesn't I'm not
talking about Oaths I'm not talking
about any of those things um we're just
saying basically that um that's already
a known Factor
um the other piece here is it only
implies to government of course and and
public employees members you know you
know if they're appointed some to some
executive state government you know
Council or
Association
um the part of in a sense reporting
false testimony is not to have a gotcha
it's not to um um go after these people
for a crime it's it's not any of those
things um I think it keeps people honest
and since we don't have Oaths that are
going on or any of that kind of stuff
which we see all the time in other
legislatur across the country as well as
in our federal government I think having
this in place um gets it key that there
is a pathway um I have been in the
legislature this is my second term but
before that I came to hearings all the
time and I would watch agencies give
false testimony all the time and I could
give multitudes of examples which I will
email the committee um where I'm going
to show you the video what they said and
what is actually the truth um a few
years back actually in our HHS committee
there was an attorney that was um so
hired by
DHHS um that was providing false
testimony and was spoken to I don't know
if it was reported to ethics I think it
was um and then he just didn't come
testify anymore this makes it a formal
process so let's say for example um
there's someone here and they're giving
a lot of false testimony um on a you
know whether it be legislature whatever
it may be current rsas laws whatever
that's in place and you as a committee
come together when you're caucusing and
you realize that that's you know not
true you can actually just put in a
formal complaint into ethics and they
could look at it if they wanted to go
further and do an investigation or call
witnesses they have we have all of that
Authority I just think that there should
be a pathway and something that is set
in stone um that says when you're coming
here to testify you're it's it's a given
that you're supposed to be telling the
truth and if you're not telling the
truth you could be held accountable and
we already have all of those Pathways
that can be done so even if this bill
isn't passed we already have um so for
example the committee could pull the
information together chair would report
to ethics ethics if they wanted to take
action like if they want to do a
criminal penalty they go for to the AG
for a criminal charge they could induce
a resolution to the house to recommend
investigation those are all things that
we have right now in our Tools in our
toolbox um the Ethics Committee could
even conduct uh their own investigation
cross-examine in um get Witnesses they
could issue a report um they could refer
to the house for a vote for contempt the
house of course has constitutional
punishment power um that can vote to
prohibit that person from testifying
before the house um I think it's really
interesting to say to be clear here that
a lot of this has to do with separation
of powers um a lot of this has to do
with um you know when an executive
branch is employing they you know if
they're testifying they're not
testifying usually as a natural person
with their rights they're testifying in
their quote unquote official capacity
and so they only have privileges the
Privileges here are are all always
designated to the people now of course
if someone comes in and um they've taken
the vacation day from their from their
job whether they work for an agency or
let's say they're you know a New
Hampshire state trooper or whatever it
may be that's all fine and dandy so then
we're all on the same level playing
field but when you're in a sense um and
I wanted to say it's clear and statute
it I think it was
421 times that I saw um I'm I won't
burden the committee with that um it's
clear in Statute in law and in even our
constitution um any person so for
example 141
c21 um they all it automatically has a
different layer for the people versus
the government any person who shall
violate disobey refuse omit or neglect
to comply with any of the provisions of
RSA 141c or the rules adopted pursuant
to it shall be guilty of a misdemeanor
if a natural person or guilty of a
felony if any other person that would be
government so government does not have
rights it has granted duties authorities
and privileges this is covered very
clearly in Worster V Plymouth it was
universally understood by the founders
of our institutions that jury trial and
other usual provisions of Bill of Rights
were not grants of rights to the public
body politic but reservations of private
rights of the subject Paramount to all
governmental Authority and this
constitutional principle has never been
abandoned so that's kind of where I'm at
if you know the committee would be open
to you know if they feel as if it's you
know too harsh to list literally the
criminal penalties in there we could
discuss that I just think it should be
stated that um having this in law in
statute is
important thank you for your testimony
um
questions representative Barton yes
thank you Mr chairman um I have just one
simple question um you you spoke about
uh a witness that you know gave false
testimony what was the bir you used uh
to determine that that witness did so
knowingly if you're talking about the
incident that I wasn't part of that
committee with the lawyer that has
nothing to do with me uh the burden of
proof if if we're talking about
something else where I was at a bill and
I was testifying this had to do with a
department stating that stating fact
that they do not promote um they didn't
didn't promote a certain um uh biologic
injection for children at all and then
um said that it was nowhere on their
website we went and saw the posting
right on their website like a flyer
promoting it and then within two days of
that hearing then magically that flyer
was disappeared online so we were in the
hearing they were told it is you're
saying here you don't do it and then
you're telling parents to do it it's
clear as day right on your website um on
the department's website on the
government website and then of course it
magically disappears that's a great
example I could give follow
up um how did you know that the
witness had that knowledge in their
head because they doubled down after
they were told that it was specifically
right there on the website they
literally said no it is not
so I mean that we're talking about like
a third in command at the
department
so okay um representative Wade thank you
Mr chair um so to clarify you you'd
mentioned a process going through the
Ethics Committee so in the scenario
where this uh law is
implemented would the Ethics Committee
be the ones who make that determination
that the person
knowingly
um uh made false testimony and how how
would they clear that
bar I really think that this would be
something that is probably not going to
happen very often I think once something
like this is in place I think it gives a
a pathway of accountability
um you know when people have been in the
house for a long time they know who
comes to their committees and um and who
doesn't that says that are like known
fibers like that's just kind of a thing
in the house um you know I'm not saying
anything that uh CES and Reps don't know
about and so um I think that that will
end maybe that some of that behavior I
don't believe that um yes they would I
think the Ethics Committee would make
that based upon the evidence that was
provided from the committee from the
chair of the committee specifically if
there was a caucus and that would there
was a problem um and to be honest I
think that it would just prove probably
a a discussion a notice a warning from
ethics to say hey that seems like that
was out of line whether we can prove
that you knowingly did or not but you
know can you be careful in the future I
think holding everyone accountable to
include everyone that's sitting in this
room all the legislators um and all
government employees is important and I
further questions oh representative
Turka welcome representative pend I have
uh one question for you um on both of
the um New paragraphs it talks about the
individual being prohibited from
testifying before the committee what is
the timeline on that that would just be
within the term because you can't bind
any future um you can't b a future
legislative uh do you know what I'm
saying
the yes but the
these these paragraphs apply to an
employee of a state agency so why would
the a term determine how long the
individual
can't I I see what you're saying I just
think that this it would be um I yeah
you're right because they're not it's
not like they are an elected rep
representative I just um I just didn't
want to have something where I thought
it was a maybe a conflict in putting
something in that was going to um you
know even bind the next leg you know the
next legislature um so I think that
that's enough I mean if you think about
it let's say if it's the beginning of
the term and this happens and they're
not able to um to testify in a committee
for a year or a year and a half um then
that's you know um I think that's enough
of a punishment in a sense that maybe
they come back and they've learned their
lesson for you know the next term so I
don't have really any problem with that
piece um I also like if it's someone
that's a repeat offender then that's
where you know maybe maybe penalties
like real penalties come in I I can't
see that happening at this point I think
that this bill will correct a problem
that we've had for quite some time
one is it your intention with this
legislation to prohibit that person uh
unilaterally from testifying or or
testifying from the agency could could
that person still come and testify sign
up with a pink card and testify as
themselves of course they could yes okay
yeah thank you very much for your up I
have one followup all right sorry thank
you wores um so uh last question so um
assuming with the amendment you said any
house committee so would that then mean
if they were found liable for providing
false testimony under one committee they
would be barred from testifying in their
Capac in their state capacity from any
committee corre at all okay correct
really good question and uh sorry last
follow up so and I think you said any
house
committee yes correct so would not apply
to the Senate um actually this is it
applies to the general court so the
general court is the Senate so we would
apply to them as well okay thank
you um all good thank you thank you very
much for your testimony um we are past
the time I'm going to no other pink
cards I will need one from you um I will
close the hearing on House Bill 315 and
while we reset the label on the
testimony table um and then we will be
the time pass the state of time of 145 I
will open the hearing on House Bill 456
and call the prime sponsor
representative
Penza who's asked for three
minutes welcome
back I never really left thank you um
thank you Mr chair um this is a real
simple Bill uh it's adding basically uh
two lines to current statute um 17 de
and 98 F1 um
um because here we have um a state
agency they shall only provide
information to the committee at the
committee's request and shall not take a
position in support of or in opposition
to a matter before the legislature um
and the reason and then there's um this
just modifies in section line 14 98 F1
um it just basically it's another piece
of legislation that just talks about
state employees wearing Badges and we
just added that in there too OLS did to
make sure it was covered in both places
um the reason why this is so important
is because um there
is we have a we have a problem with um
testimony coming in all of the time to
they're giving factual information and
then um and then they're saying oh well
you know you shouldn't pass this bill
because and there's a lot of I guess the
word is wha ifs there's tons of wha ifs
when um the separation of powers is so
important and uh we've kind of lost our
way with that um so coming in as a as an
agency presenting factual information um
is important um when there's a lot of
whatif
uh so for example in my committee it
happens all of the time um there's just
an undue influence that we know that's
taking place um public comment for
example on rules that took place uh that
got passed were it was unbelievable to
watch there was not one private person
not one expert that came in that was for
the rules and then um now every bill
that we had to fix some of those rules
through all that testimony was Den dened
from the agency when all of the
testimony that we have um based upon the
public from the private people was all
in support of everything that we've done
um because there's you know private
meetings that take place with industry
and and stakeholders and um or even the
executive branch and those things have
to stop they really have to be very
separate so facts are important in
presenting it um someone can basically
rip apart a bill by not saying that they
are for or against uh by give just
giving the facts that are stated and
that's what's so important and I think
what's really if you look at the rules
of the house this is what we have passed
um rule 63 is clear influencing
legislation proh Pro prohibition of no
employee or adese of the house sergeant
of arms shall directly or indirectly be
personally involved with or or attempt
to influence the passage or
consideration of any measure whatsoever
if any such employee or attache becomes
involved with any such measure it shall
be grounds for summary
dismissal so we have those rules for us
but we're not giving those same rules to
other branches like the executive branch
for example um so the executive branch
is not given this type of authority um
the governor is given executive power to
Faithfully make sure that the laws are
followed and there's just our
constitution is so clear um with our our
legislature you know part one article
two um it's just it talks about you know
the supreme legislative power within the
state shall be vested in the Senate and
the House of Representatives each will
have you know a negative on uh on the
other which really shows that checks and
balances um Article 5 is very clear so I
just really um that I've talked to other
fellow reps that are now in their second
term and third term um that are very
supportive of this as well um there
shouldn't be anyone that um it just
basically keeps keeps things clean keeps
checks and balances and um makes you
know government employees um when
they're coming in in those capacities
basically talk on merits and use facts
done that questions sure sure um see
representative wait thank you Mr chair
um so have other questions specifically
on line 11 uh of the bill um which
states that a state agency shall only
provide information to the committee at
the committee's request so in the
context of something like a public
hearing with that then mean that the
committee would have to request a state
agency to come ahead of time um so what
what what does at the committee's
request mean in the context of of
providing that
information so when we have a hearing
that's we're already requesting it from
that so ol this is their language and
they said that this was that's how it
should be written here specifically when
they added that line um that's their
legal language so
um we right now we put an a we have a
public hearing we have it open that's
basically we're requesting information
for people to come in so if that is of
course a private person or someone that
is an agency that's that's how it works
and so that's why I was told that
because I picked up on that as well but
that's that's the language that they'
used yes
[Music]
so to to understand so the the standard
of a public hearing counts as the
committee's request so to my
understanding um state employees or
state
agencies wouldn't need to have um
addition a specific request from the
committee for bills to come in and
testify for they would still be able to
come in on their own
accord of course that's the standard
that it is now that doesn't change at
all um as you know and representative
Hill you've been doing this for a while
um that does happen of course chairs uh
you know request people to come in um
request agencies to come in request
other people to come back up and speak
on something to maybe ask another
question that's all um standard but it's
not changing any sort of process
placees representative Barton thank you
um I would follow on uh representative
Wade's um questions and concerns about
line 11 this the the language here says
a state agency shall shall only provide
um limiting the the state agency if I'm
reading the language like that uh my my
question is um
and I'll I'll say that the house can
pass resolutions and those res
resolutions can be delivered to the
federal government and so I think it's
Federalist 45
um essentially makes the state a
constituent of of the federal government
uh so my question would be would would a
state agency or a representative of a
state agency constitute a um constituent
of the state and would they would they
be limited um in providing information
based on the language of um of 10 and 11
in this proposed
legislation I don't believe so
um I can look into that further talk
with one of the attorneys to see but um
you know if that created an issue then
you know we could we could fix that
language um like I said I was I made it
Crystal Clear of what the bill was um
which was can't take a position provide
factual information um and that's it
they wrote that like that specifically
because it's kind of known hearing they
come in of course we already know that
Representatives chairs Vice chairs
request you know expert testimony that
are coming in from government agencies
all the time so if that seems to be an
issue we can fix that that's not a
problem um if we feel that it
is um if if the uh if the agency is
considered a
constituent um wouldn't they have the
rights to to uh take a
position they have to come in they would
have to not be on their work hours so um
coming in in their private capacity
yes they can take whatever position they
capacity thank you Mr chairman thank you
for your testimony represent potential
what happens if a bill comes in and I
don't have an example of the top of my
head um that truly negatively impacts
the practices of a particular agency
that agency is not able to defend itself
then or
what no I mean I I if they're um the
legislature creates the law so if they
want to come in and they want to testify
in their own private capacity as an
employee of an agency they have every
right to do that but they can't
represent the agency but they can give
all of the facts it's very easy to say
to say you know I we strongly oppose
this bill for XYZ just don't say you
strongly oppose the bill but these are
the reasons why I I feel or even an
agency can come in and say this
bill I feel on behalf of the agency is
inherently flawed because of X Y and Z
it's about taking a position they can't
you can't come in and say we're strongly
opposed to this we strongly support this
that's what I'm saying because that's
the gaming of the system that is a
problem the legislature makes ra laws we
have separation of powers we have to
keep it as clean as we possibly can
facts are facts and that's great it's
not going to stop anything you know I
want as much truthful factual
information for us to be able to do our
jobs as best we
can represent
senson thank you Mr chair and thank you
for your bill um so you mentioned the
executive branch earlier and it's my
understanding that the governor's budget
is a proposal that she's advocating for
so she's specifically taking a stand how
bill so um it really doesn't because she
doesn't come testify in front of the
legislature the the bill actually
goes I mean going through one budget
already I've kind of watched that
process and when we get you know s when
we get like um s sp1 and sb2 we're you
know and all of the different components
to it um her proposal is put forward and
then it goes to the legislature it's not
as if she's coming in and testifying or
for or against or whatever it's it it
doesn't really work in what I'm talking
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
your testimony can I clarify a statement
that you just made that the governor
does not um provide testimony to all of
us when it's on our calendar that the
governor is making your budget
address yes I know that was confusing no
I understand where you're coming from
she of course puts forward in her
address to the whole house we're talking
about like a specific Bill item she's
going to give her you know put her foot
forward but this is It's I'm not I don't
know I think we're making this bigger
into than what we than what we're saying
here I don't um the budget is a little
bit different than just passing uh one
legislation thank you chairman um
question please I believe I've seen um
where like for example the state police
come in and testify on a committee are
you saying they would have to come in on
their own time to testify about
legislation and how it might affect
their operations they'd have to come in
as a private citizen they couldn't come
in while they're on the job no they
could totally come in while they're on
representative B yes I have a a question
this goes back to considering if we were
considering a estate agency as a
constituent uh would we be restricting
their rights to um say yay or or nay if
they're on the clock why wouldn't they
be able to to come in on on the clock
because taxpayers are paying for for
them and they they can't you can't you
can't do that the government doesn't
have the right to do that that's the
separation of powers and that's why um
we that's why it would be different if
they're going to take a day off from
work and they want to speak and go
against or for something then then that
is um that's their right to do that as a
private citizen in their private
capacity but as a paid employee of the
state if they're going to come in and
say I strongly
oppose they can't do
that if if we were yes if we were to um
as as a how the governor were to to
deliver a house resolution to let's say
the president would they have to do it
on their own personal
time if the governor was to deliver a
resolution for I don't understand what
you're saying if if the the the Senate
and the house passed let's say a joint
house resolution on subject X and the
governor signed it uh and subject X is
now a passed resolution would that
resolution have to be delivered to uh
our federal delegation or to the Office
of the President uh on the governor's
personal time or would it be able to be
delivered on state state taxpayers time
a resolution is not
apply I'm new at
this um I'm going to ask private citizen
again thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee I am Sean Jasper private
citizen Hudson representing myself um
and I apologize because my three monkeys
comment was actually meant to be for
this bill not the previous
one um
and I think there are a lot of a lot of
problems uh with this idea and and the
first one I want to correct is just
because some people have not seen a
governor come and testify before
committee does not mean that it does not
happen because I've certainly served in
the legislature when it has happened um
as Speaker I had
encouraged Governor sonunu to come and
testify just for pick a bill any Bill to
come in and testify so that committee
members would become familiar with how
that happened unfortunately I don't
think that did and clearly now there's
some idea that Governors don't testify
on bills but I'm sure that
representative wall could testify that
over the years that has happened on more
than one occasion
um the idea that we we could come in and
provide
information um as a head of a state
agency without directly or
indirectly um taking a position is is
counterintuitive if you're providing
information there are going to be times
when it's very clear what the position
is based on the information that we're
providing and that would be in the
testimony would be in conflict with what
you just heard I'm going to give you a
uh an example of a bill that I will be
testifying on um in this session uh as a
matter of fact when I was asked for
fiscal note I refused to provide the
information because it this said the
bill is a direct violation of federal
law and I will not provide information
on a bill which violates federal law and
so I will be testifying and I have to
testify to the consequences of that bill
and why I have to oppose it because
while the intent may be
good the reality is that it would put
private
citizens at risk of violating public
federal law being subject to a
misdemeanor and $1,000 fine per
violation but they would be doing so
under cover of estate law and in this
this particular subject which has to do
197 the federal government has taken it
on their responsibility for food
protection um you can actually read my
comments on on uh the website of the
department with my uh my weekly column
which I don't necessarily write weekly
but this one is called The Jungle which
is a reference to uh uh the book The
Jungle written by Upton Sinclair in
194 um so there are times when it is in
the best interest and it is imperative
for departments to be giving that uh
that testimony that could be very
directly uh in opposition to the bill
simply giving information first of all
as I said would pretty easily be seen
one way or the other but it is
imperative the second uh case is and the
government just gave all the
Commissioners and department heads this
directive yesterday we are not to
testify on bills unless we have had the
approval of the governor to do so
because specifically she does not want
us to be at odds with her position so we
have to run it through her office to say
we have a bill that we have we're either
in support or opposition to and we would
like to testify then we get the
permission to do so so you know we need
to be able to represent the person who
appointed us to office we are in essence
here on the governor's behalf I think
you need to have the information and and
you all need to do as the legislature
has done for you know if you go back to
Colonial times well over 300 years you
have to take the information that is
provided to you in weigh that rather
it's truth truthful whether it makes
sense to
you and and use that to come to your
best judgment but you should not put the
legislature in a in a situation where
there are opinions and thoughts and
ideas that are held back I think that
goes against the very idea of why the
legisl is here and I'll I'll end my
testimony there thank you uh private
citizen U Jasper um any any
questions yes representative way thank
you for your testimony um so I'm I'm a
freshman rep but it's to my
understanding that there are occasions
where a state agency might reach out to
a legislator um or um and and discuss
proposing a bill in the first place if
there um if if a state agency identifies
an issue with current law or an
improvement that could be made um
specifically to benefit their operations
and then that you know that the entire
process is is in coordination with
estate agency um so how do you imagine
this might impact those types of bills
that get thank you for that question and
I did Overlook that part of the the
process in my testimony I've been
thinking of that back there and then it
slipped slipped my mind but you're
absolutely right that is the only way
that agencies can actually get a bill
before the legislature is to find
sponsors um and we do that all the time
uh there are several bills before the
before the legislature now that I have
reached out to legislature legislators
on and will be coming forward at our
behas and um we will need to testify in
favor of that we've asked legislators to
go forward with these IDE idea and these
ideas and these bills and the idea that
we wouldn't be able to come in and then
give them the full support uh again is
something that just really doesn't make
a lot of sense now we you know usually
um you will find in those cases it may
actually say this bill has been
submitted at the request of the state of
the Department of Agriculture markets
and food you'll be aware of that but
certainly most legislators would also
say the department asked me to do that
and then we would follow up with the
testimony it is part of the process that
has worked very well for hundreds of
years thank you commissioner Jasper um
you got three monkeys and a jungle all
in the same
testimony pretty good um no further
questions I think we're all set thank
you very much uh chair will
call Paul
Smith our house clerk uh asked for two
minutes
not taking a position that's correct
thank you Mr chairman for the record
Paul Smith Clerk of the house wanted to
give a little historical context uh to
this to the underlying section of uh
chapter 98 um in
2005 uh legislation uh let let me give a
more broad historical context in the
early 2000s legislative ethics was sort
of Paramount um and we revised our laws
entirely um uh former representative
Jasper was was chair of the legislative
Ethics Committee at one point uh I was a
member of the House at that time and uh
in fact uh I am a co-sponsor of the bill
uh House Bill 43 in
2005 that went to this committee um that
specifically created chapter 98f the
reason this was done was because in
2003 and four when we were working on
the legislative ethics chapter we uh we
really got into the meat of RSA
155 uh in in in the whole chapter of 15
which is about um lobbying in behalf of
in in front of the legisl excuse me in
front of the legislature and the
original um the original subsections
that we worked on uh was to create a not
applicable to State Employees who were
appearing to testify for a committee we
amended that subsequently in creating
the new chapter 98 as it was in 2005
which is now 20 years old um and
basically indicated that like lobbyists
legisl or excuse me executive branch
staff um must wear proper identification
in their positions of taking positions
just like
lobbyists just like lobbyists we were
equating legis excuse me executive
branch staff I'm a legislative staff
it's just the way I rock I apologize um
but we wanted the executive agencies to
be held to the same standard as
lobbyists who were also being paid uh to
to give a position uh in front of the
legislature so that is the history of
how this particular statute developed uh
and why um and and and to clarify that
state employees and agencies had been
for many years testifying on behalf of
their agencies and keep in mind of
course that Commissioners are
technically not included as staff of
executive of the executive branch
because they are commissioned by the
governor and Council just like the
governor is not an employee um when he
or she does testify in front of the
legislature to present their budget they
are not employees they are the Govern
governor elected
Etc um the the second point I wanted to
just raise in in the first part of
17d um in regarding investigations that
the language as representative Wade
pointed out earlier does say a state
agency shall only provide information to
the committee at the committee's request
so that means preemptively if an agency
saw House Bill 645 and saw that it was
going to to cut 45 positions the agency
could not send a letter to the committee
unless requested to do so saying this
will impact the state in the following
ways not taking a position but this
language would prohibit them from
sending that letter until they were
invited to do so by the chair of the
committee um that is that is a a truism
of of the language as it is before you
uh again I don't take any position on um
allowing uh agencies to to take a
position on on legislation uh I can
simply tell you the the legislative
intent uh from 20 years ago um when I
was sitting over on that side um and and
why we are where we
are thank you for your testimony uh
further
questions seeing none thank you very
much um chair we'll call uh John
DHHS chairman Hill committee thank you
again taking no position taking taking
no position um so this I I think you've
actually identified many of the key
concerns that I was going to raise and
you certainly got a well done history of
the legislative background from uh clerk
um Smith on on the bill uh there was
just a couple of very quick um items
just to bring to your attention um for
example the Department of Revenue
Administration they perform an important
and critical role and this is just an
example just speaking about how we work
as state agencies with with the
legislature as you go through the budget
process one of the thresholds is
identifying what are the revenues going
to be and that happens during the course
of the uh House phas of the budget the
governor phase of the budget uh and the
critical information that is received by
the house Ways and Means Committee is so
so important so this bill as currently
written would prohibit them from coming
unless they were were requested now one
of the the items that did catch my
attention uh in your discussion is about
what mechanically would the process be
for the committee themselves to actually
make the request and as as and I would
defer to attorney Jenifer for because
she's your legal counsel for the
committee on all things that are legal
but I'm going to give you at least my my
Impressions because I've been doing this
work for some time but under statutory
construction you look at the plain
language in front of you and if you read
it and it reads in a very clear way you
don't get to the ambiguity of trying to
figure out what the language means so in
the sentences that you see in lines 10
through 12 when it talks about a state
agency shall only provide information to
a committee at the committee's request
not the committee's chair that could
certainly call and say hey I would like
uh uh um commissioner Jasper to come and
talk to me about wonderful things
happening in the world of Agriculture um
apples blooming and things like that and
and all that sort of stuff but what it
says here specifically is that the
committee has to make make the request
so how does that even procedurally
happen does that mean you have to meet
as a committee convene then vote because
right to know transparency of government
you're going to have to do this in the
open public for people to see and say
yes we're voting on this bill we would
like to see the department then you
would close the hearing recalendar it
per the the um house rules and then have
the department come before you so I
think you've identified many of the the
mechanical issues and technical issues
with the bill uh as commissioner Jasper
said um and it was a great question that
was raised by repr Wade many state
agencies do request legislation to help
New Hampshire citizens and we reach out
to you and we partner with you and we
get uh if you're good at what you do you
get bip partn support you get both
senators and representatives on your
bill in the analysis of the bill when
you for those of you who are brand new
uh right under here where it says
analysis you're going to see indicated
in there if it was a department
requested bill so it makes it really
really clear that the department is
requesting that legislation so what
happens if this bill passes and clearly
the Department's wanting to come in and
taking a position on it whether it's
implied or directly and now I and it
raises a question the authority if I'm
coming here as citizen Jasper um just
for a second um or citizen Williams do I
really am I vested with the authority
that I've been given as a state um actor
at that point in time and and it just
raises lots of questions and I think you
got it so with that that ends and
concludes my observations uh chairman
Hill unless there's any questions for me
I thank you for your time and attention
are there any
questions seeing done thank you very
much um last P card that I have um is um
Masco ah um from the office of the child
advocate um welcome to legislative
Administration if you could give your
name and position with the organization
that would be
great and you do have written testimony
Bill thank you chairman Hill um my name
is attorney Lissa massio I'm the
associate child advocate againa M
massio it's Italian it's a tough one
that's an i m a c IO yes I'm sorry my
teenager also agrees with you that my
handwriting is terrible but NOP that's
great thank you very much welcome thank
you so much and I am here as the
associate child advocate essentially I
am the deputy for a very tiny agency
that many of you may not have heard of I
actually have not had the pleasure of
appearing here before you or meeting
most of you our child advocate Cassandra
Sanchez wanted to be here today but she
could not she is essentially the
commissioner of our agency um the office
of the child Advocate is a nine-person
state agency we are administratively
attached to dis because we are an
independent oversight agency
over all child serving executive branch
agency so originally that was dcyf which
is child protection Juvenile Justice it
expanded in 2020 to include all child
serving agencies executive branch
agencies as well as their contracted
providers that would also include
residential facilities like Webster
house it expands to
YDC um as well as contracted providers
like Waypoint so we are a very small
agency um but we one of the reasons we
were created in 2017 after some very
high-profile um child deaths was in part
two come present to and Advocate to the
legislature the public other executive
branch agencies um Outreach is a huge
part of what we do um so I did include a
big chunk of our Statute in the written
testimony I tried to bold the relevant
pieces um I just want to point to a
couple things because I agree with
private citizen Jasper who has left as
well as my colleague John Williams um
many of us sit on a commissioner
legislative group which is a group of
all of the sort of legislative Liaisons
in state agencies um to come together on
some bills so I did read that sentence
in the same way that you did represent
representative Wade as far as the
invitation the request to appear I agree
with attorney Williams that that is the
plain language of that it would seem as
though unless the entire committee
invited us to appear we could not
present
testimony and um as many of you may not
have been aware the office of the child
advocate exists or that we might be
interested in this bill so you wouldn't
even know to invite us or request Our
Testimony um we were created to
specifically Advocate and give a voice
to children in the system very
vulnerable children who often don't have
a voice um which is a little different
than many state agencies most state
agencies were not created specifically
for that purpose even though they do
that um and so there are many bills I am
currently watching over 150 bills right
now many of which may not appear on
their face to impact children in the
system however we are the experts in
that area I was a dcyf attorney
Prosecuting child use I've been a parent
attorney contracted with the state I've
also practiced private family law most
of my colleagues are social workers
they've worked within the system and
without this of the system we are
experts in our field as are most of the
state agency employees I would hope that
state agencies hire experts in their
fields so they know about land use I sat
through a bill on farming today there's
a there's a specific agency may be
implicated or that children may be
implicated or that there may be an
unintended consequence for children so
we are particularly concerned about that
language but more broadly this idea that
state agencies should not be able to
directly or indirectly take a position
does seem to fly in the face of what we
do I appreciate your question about the
budget every agency has to go before the
house finance and the Senate finance
committee and Advocate sometimes quite
strongly for our budget to get funding
especially in a challenging uh fiscal
climate we also do have bills as
attorney Williams mentioned and uh
commissioner Jasper mentioned that our
agency put forth and it says right on
there put forth by the office of child
advocate the uh Bill language for sb76
just came out it's a cleanup bill for
our statute we would necessarily need to
go advocate for that about why those
specific changes what needs to get fixed
so as everyone else has already
mentioned that the language of this is
incredibly problematic for many
reasons and would directly impact the
office of child advocate especially
because we have sort of a very unique
role and I'd be happy to take any
questions thank you for your testimony
uh I see one question one hand raised
from representative
Richards just for clarification in the
notes that I was taking um in this
language that we're many of folks that
are testimony or pointing to around the
invit the invitation of the committee um
just to clarify that that is that
invitation is something that committees
do with every single bill at the point
with every when every public hearing is
announced so the statement from OS is
that that is the committee's invitation
did I hear
that correctly but did I then also hear
that um the agencies like yourself may
be wanting to provide information as the
clerk listed with the historical in uh
intent of things that there would be
times when an agency would send a letter
to the committee in in advance of the
public hearing being stated so they're
aware at the start of the legislative
session this bill is coming forward with
certain language that's going to cut the
45 employees as was mentioned earlier
and at that point that anyone from that
state agency could not do anything until
announced is are you following my logic
I heard to whom is that question I'm
kind of putting that question to you um
and then I would also then put it back
to the sponsor of the bill potentially
to come back up because she did say that
OS put that in my area of wanting to
find the focus of concern is that you're
restricting any of that agency to do
anything until that public hearing is
scheduled and announced so my
understanding if you'll allow me my
understanding is um the notice in the
calendar of the hearing date is um the
offer to all um to um testify on this on
this bill so um whether that's quote
unquote an invitation I think I think it
would be um so regardless of whether um
there's a personal invitation or not or
um and and I did write down the note of
um we may not even know they want to
testify um I think it's encompassing or
um uh incumbent on them um or whoever
them is to to read the calendar and
that's the
may I follow up Mr chair yeah my my I
guess I let me re try to restate this to
be where I'm trying to get into the
order of operations of what is
restricting the state agencies is that
um the state agency will only provide
information at the committee at the
committee's request um the committee's
request is the public hearing which is
calendared um and the agencies pay
attention to that you follow your 100 50
bills that language though is the state
agency can only provide information at
that point from that point forward so
from February 19th on the rest of the
eight bills no state agency could
communicate with the committee in any
fashion and that to me is what this is
saying and if as Paul gave an example
that a bill could be presented that cuts
half of the workforce that no one the
the commissioner appointed by the
governor no one could communicate to
anyone in the committee prior to that
point okay so here's what we'll do um we
will ask um both Jennifer and um
attorney CN for for whether for
clarification on that
point okay
good s way I I was G to quick this isn't
a question it's more to to state that I
think the the prime sponsor mentioned
that OSS said that that language implied
that the hearing counted as the
committee's request but there are
concerns from some of the other
witnesses that the plain language of the
bill if you were to just read it in
isolation um a committee might think
that you would have to get a formal
request so yeah
you're I think everybody has covered it
I think it's an open question that is my
plain read reading of it that we would
need to wait for a committee to reach
out to the office of child advocate and
say please we want you to speak to us
because it's new language the the
original language sort of had that as a
public
invitation okay we'll get it clarified
representative turkot thank you um Mr
chairman thanks for the question this is
probably a better question for the
sponsor but I'll take your response on
it also let's just assume that the words
at the committee's request was not in
there uh I think would you at that point
think that the intent of the bill is to
have agencies or state employees only
provide inform provide information and
not take a
position does that make sense yes so
so we have two distinct concerns with
this bill one being the invitation only
the second very much being that agencies
would not not be able to take a position
and I think commissioner Jasper as well
as attorney Williams
also said similarly whether you're
indirectly or directly taking aition you
know the office of the child advocate is
very specifically created in order to
advocate for children which would make
it incredibly difficult for us to
fulfill our statutory mandate but I
think many state agencies it's very
clear even if you're just giving
information like this is going to harm
the environment this is going to harm
children this is going to harm the state
police what you know whatever or help it
could also be helped this will help
children this will help State Police
typically when a state agency is
weighing in it's because the bill is
going to have some sort of impact on
their agency or more importantly their
constituency um the office of child
advocate was very specifically
created in order to be sort of a
watchdog agency and specifically take
positions and systemic reform um but all
agencies um do directly or indirectly
take positions including on our budgets
as well as bills that we put forth uh
right now we have five bills in front of
the legislature that we sought a sponsor
we help draft we provide assistance and
advocacy for um so this would definitely
tie the hands of I believe All State
agencies but very explicitly the office
of the child advocate H up thank you Mr
chairman uh
let me rephrase the question uh if the
words at the committee's request were
removed is it fair to say you'd only
have one issue with this bill and that
would be not being able to provide a
um position correct except for it is
worded differently the second the second
section in 98 F1 is even
broader um to include promoting opposing
directly or indirectly any legislation
it'd be hard to imagine how I would even
give information without potentially
falling a foul of that language is
incredibly
broad um very quickly um would you
information thank you for the
question that feels a little bit like a
chicken in an egg
question um a position yes taking a
information thank you um no further
questions seeing none thank you very
much for your help um it's a pleasure to
see all of you we never get to hang out
over uh you're always welcome back at
the legislative Administration I do see
a hand up from the prime sponsor who um
I hesitate but I would be happy to give
you two or three minutes to uh answer
whatever questions have popped up in the
like thank you Mr chair
um position is Crystal Clear it's Pro or
against you know the first thing comes
out of the mouth usually when an agency
is testifying we're strongly against or
strongly for that's the only thing that
this
changes I just talked to um commissioner
Jasper in the hallway I see him all the
time I'm an environment and agricult
being any of that if it's going to
violate federal law and you're going to
give all of those facts all of that
information it's about taking a position
specifically that's it so whoever you're
advocating for or not I didn't realize
that this would be ripped apart I
thought it was a simple bill I
definitely believe that if the committee
is up for that I will put an amendment
in or the commit it's your bill now um
you could put an amendment in to wipe
out the specific language that was from
OS um in regards because you know and
and look at the um talk to the attorney
as well it was Jennifer that I worked
with on this bill um so you know we
could fix that it's just um I think it's
it's really important
um and there's there's a method to my
madness and I will uh I will email the
committee some very specifics about the
reason why I think that's so
important um when you're arguing your
case for some for something or against
something um the proof is in the pudding
and they're going to be they're already
doing that anyway this doesn't change
that okay this um I wasn't giving you a
second opportunity to do another
testimony um I I wondered if you had
specific answers to specific questions
that we had so um representative
Richards I um I see I heard exactly what
you heard from um um from the clerk and
so um now I don't believe that we ever
get any testimony Before the bill gets
gets a bill number and all of that it's
before it goes onto the calendar and has
a hearing it's not as if I've never
received any sort of testimony in
advance of a bill that's not already
noticed so that piece I agree like the
hearing with what the OS put forward was
that was like the putting it out there
inviting but um I can see where you're
coming from with what he said like if
that continuing you know would it be a
One-Shot deal I wouldn't believe that I
that was not my intent uh we get
messages all the time for from the um
agencies all throughout the cycle it's
not a one and done so but I I hear what
you were trying to say and I I think
that that was a concern that um the cler
answered for you great thank you very
much for taking the time uh having no
other pink cards and seeing no one else
in the room that uh wants to speak I'll
close the hearing on whatever this bill
is uh
um I will uh I think we're all set for
the day um we've successfully gone
through a third of our
bills um and uh and we're all set now
for the we will be in the calendar
tonight for the
19th um anything that comes up please
let me know in the meantime um anything
for how things went today um was there
anything that you wanted to bring up I
know sorry I kind of slipped a little
bit into ex session on that that last
one no no no no make sure I
yeah so for a little while just about
till crossover you can get away with
saying I'm new here but after that um uh
we're all we're all the same um it
is um everything comes through the chair
so even even um even if you know the
answer to something um it would be
better it you you read the room and and
sometimes along the way it would be
better we have we have all this period
of time between now and exing to have
the conversation um and so you know it's
it it's perfectly fine don't don't let
it worry you um anything else anyone
have a problem you did an excellent job
with that new system thank you um I
don't think there's uh any
other information um we're fine um
attorney Port are we
fine thank you all right uh have a good